>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Abbey Potter: Hello.
I am Abbey Potter.
I'm with the Library of Congress
labs team and we're really happy
to host the HTRC and their
text mining workshop today.
This is a topic we're
very interested in.
We-- The library also has--
like I'm sure many of your
institutions has loads
of copyright or restricted
materials
and we're always interested
to find ways to use that
and make it useful to our users.
So, we're really looking
forward to this workshop.
So I will turn it
over to Harriett
and she will get us started.
Is that right?
OK.
>> Harriett Green: Yes.
So we love to-- we really like
to thank Abbey and Jaime Mears
for inviting us here at
the Library of Congress.
So we're really excited to talk
with you today about HathiTrust
and text mining and how
US librarians can start
to engage in this research.
So, just as we-- just to
start up with a quick--
we're going to do
introductions that again
as Abbey said won't be filmed.
My name is Harriett Green.
I'm the PI for this project.
And I'll be accompanied
by, well,
[inaudible] with
Eleanor Dickson,
also from the University of
Illinois, and Amanda Henley
from the University
of North Carolina
and she'll be circulating.
So definitely keep an eye
out for Amanda as you go
through the process
and you need help.
So just to give a
quick introduction
about the project itself
and kind of the context
that we're doing this work
today, so we received a grant
from the IMLS about--
in 2015 to carry
out this project that's really
aimed at empowering librarians
to engage with digital
scholarship
and giving you the basic
foundational tools and skills
to start talking with
faculty, working with faculty
in any context that you work in,
so that we're not just thinking
about digital scholarship
librarians but subject liaisons,
technical services, librarians,
archivists, all contexts
that librarians are starting to
engage with digital scholarship.
So you can see, all of you
should have visited our website
by this point,
teach.htrc.illinois.edu.
And these are the
goals, the formal goals
that we stated for the project.
Again, this workshop
is aiming to arm you
with some instructional
content as well as tool skills.
So everything that
you downloaded today,
all the slides, all
the materials,
they're here for you to use.
So we really love to hear
your stories afterward
of how you're actually using
this content as well to teach
and work with students
and faculty.
And then kind of the larger
goals, empowering librarians
to become research
partners on digital projects
and we'll do some
discussions throughout the day
to think about that.
And then thinking about as
digital scholarship centers
and services are emerging
on your campuses, you know,
enabling you to start engaging
with those centers and all
of the different
initiatives that are happening
on a lot of our campuses.
So, first and foremost,
I want to thank the team
that put this workshop together,
that put all the
materials together,
certainly it isn't just
me-- and it's not just me,
not just Eleanor and Amanda,
but a whole cohort of people.
So, in addition, the co-PIs are
Angela Courtney from Indiana,
Stephen Downie from the
School of Information Sciences
at Illinois, Teresa Heidenwolf
from Lafayette College,
Geoff Morse from Northwestern,
and Amanda from North Carolina.
And that also highlights
that we're not just coming
from a research library
perspective,
there's a nice array of types
of libraries that we're coming
from as we created this
workshop curriculum.
So we're trying to account
for all the different types
of library context that
you'll be working in.
And then the project members
are really the backbone
of this work.
In particular, I want
to highlight Eleanor,
who along with Leanne
Nay and Ruohua Han,
because they wrote
this curriculum.
So they did a lot
of the hard work
to put these materials
together, so I really want
to thank them as well.
So, this is our first
module that's going
to really give you an
introduction to text analysis
and thinking about what
it is, giving you kind
of a larger framework.
And then we're also
going to talk
about the HathiTrust
Research Center
that we'll be working
with today as well.
So again, this module, we'll
talk about text analysis,
what it means to do
workflows with text analysis.
We'll then talk a little
bit about the HathiTrust
and the HathiTrust Research
Center and the context
that we'll be using
to start thinking
about text analysis
with this resource.
And then we'll also
introduce the hands-on example
and case study that we'll
be using throughout the day
that will again give you a
framework and reference point
for how text analysis works and
how US librarians can also start
to work with text analysis.
So, first of all,
what is text analysis?
So let's start with
just the basics.
So what it is and the definition
that we'll be using is
that text analysis is a subset
of data mining and
data analysis.
And broadly speaking,
it's the process
by which computers are used
to reveal information
in and about text.
And we took this definition
from Marti Hearst 2003 article
that you can see in our provided
bibliography both at the end
of the slides and
on our website.
So, what we-- with
text analysis,
computer algorithms
can discern patterns in
and about the text often
when it's bodies of
unstructured text.
And unstructured means
that little is known
about the semantic
meaning of the text data
and it doesn't fit a defined
data model or database.
So an algorithm, and we'll
revisit this again later today,
is simply a process by which--
a computational process
by which output is created
from certain input.
So in text analysis,
the input is the text
and then the algorithm
works on the text
and the output would
be indicators
to help you discern
patterns about that text.
And text analysis is
more about search.
It's not just search and
discovery, but it's also
that something is
present in that text.
So exploring what does
it mean for that pattern,
for that thing to be there.
So for example, knowing that
creativity appears x number
of times in a text is
only the first step.
We then want to know
what the patterns
about its appearance
tell us about culture,
tell us about history,
et cetera.
And text analysis can be
used in a variety of purposes
and actually each of you in your
everyday lives have probably
encountered text analysis
in many different contexts.
So in a scholarly
realm, it's been used
to analyze scientific
literature and to pick up trends
in medical research to discern
things that might have happened
that otherwise you don't see
in individual articles or just
in a year's span of
medical literature.
But it can also be used
in developing tools.
So in your email, when you-- the
spam that your email picks up
and tosses into another folder,
that's using text analysis
because it's discerning
patterns and emails to say,
this is a rogue email,
it's not useful,
I'm going to put it
in the spam folder.
So we're each-- we're
all interacting
with text analysis
actually every day.
So, how does text
analysis work in general?
So text analysis usually
follows these basic steps.
So first, the text needs to
be transformed into a form
that human readers are
familiar with into something
that the computer can "read".
So this means that we often
need to break apart the text
into smaller pieces
and reduce it
in what we call abstracting
it into something
that the computer can read
and crunch through algorithms.
And then counting is
what happens next.
So often, the computer will
count words, phrases of speech,
parts of speech, different--
whatever you define it to be
so that it can start
processing the text.
And these counts are used
to identify characteristics
of the text.
And then the researches
apply the algorithms,
often computational statistics
to develop hypotheses based
on the patterns they're seeing
from those counts in the text.
So how does this
impact research?
So again, let's think
about the broader context
of what does this mean for text
analysis to be used in research.
So in general, text analysis
enables a shift in perspective
of the researcher
which leads to a shift
in the research questions.
And so, this is often
called distant reading
and this is a phrase
coined by Franco Moretti,
a Stanford professor, meaning
that when you do
distant reading,
you're not just reading
literature
by studying particular
text, which is traditional
for close reading
but by aggregating
and analyzing massive
amounts of text
and "reading them
from a distance".
So the scaling up in
this distancing can bring
out more insights but from a
very different vantage point.
And it's also worth mentioning
that text analysis is
not the end all be all.
It's really one step in
the research process.
And it can be combined
often with close reading
and this is what we might
call intermediate reading
or distant close reading.
And the shift in research
perspective then allows
for shifts in research
questions,
so that old questions
can sometimes be answered
in new ways.
So some of the possibilities
that text analysis open
up is questions that
you can't prove
by doing human reading alone.
A human can't read a
million books in one sitting
or even years of sitting.
So what-- how do we enable
computers to help us with that?
And by that token, it allows
larger corpora for analysis
by aggregating and analyzing
mass amounts of text.
And then it allows
for textual studies
that cover longer time spans
as well, again, by aggregating
and analyzing those
larger corpora of text.
Text analysis research
explores a wide range of topics
and we heard from some of these
examples address certain issues,
so from biomedical
discovery to literate history
to religious history,
and what really comes
down to is the research
question itself.
And the research questions
that are particularly conducive
to text analysis methods often
involve these characteristics.
So one is change over time.
So are we seeing changes?
Pattern recognition and
identifying patterns
that might be useful to know,
and then comparative analysis
as well, so how our works--
you know, identifying
different changes in works
or interesting things and
comparing these works.
So, let's look at some
real-world examples
that show these characteristics
as well as demonstrate impacts
on the research that
we discussed earlier.
So, let's take about
three, four minutes.
And in your tables or
you can turn around,
you can go to this URL,
go.illinois.edu and then look
at the research examples.
We have three research--
types of research questions
with text analysis and discuss,
you know, how-- what do
these projects involve change
over time, pattern recognition,
and/or comparative analysis,
what kind of text
data do they use,
and what are their findings?
So let's take a minute to go
through these and just kind
of discuss a bit more and maybe
verify what you guys thought
about which-- what are the
answers to these questions.
So the first example
that we looked
at was a well-known example.
And it's using a method
that we call stylometry.
And so involved when
"Cuckoo's Calling"
by Robert Galbraith
was published in 2013,
people wondered if the
book was actually written
by J.K. Rowling.
So the research question is,
did J.K. Rowling write the
"Cuckoo's Calling" under the
pen name Robert Galbraith?
And that's kind of impossible to
prove just by reading the book.
And so as we heard earlier
with another question,
you get the sense that,
maybe something is here
but you're not entirely certain.
So it involves comparative
analysis, didn't make it that,
and comparing "Cuckoo's
Calling" with other books
by J.K. Rowling, and
then recognizing patterns
between her writing
and the writing that's
in "Cuckoo's Calling".
And you see at the citation at
the bottom is the full study
by Patrick Juola
and he was a scholar
who explored this question.
So what he did is that
human reading led to a hunch
about the authorship question,
then Patrick Juola conducted
a stylometry analysis
to complete a computational
comparison of diction
between the book and
others written by Rowling,
the "Harry Potter" series.
So by comparing a set
of linguistic variables
between the text of "Cuckoo's
Calling" for their text,
one by Rowling and three
others by other authors,
so as to extract her text,
the results suggested
that J.K. Rowling's style was
the closest to Cuckoo's Calling.
And so this provided a
ton of statistical proof
of an authorial fingerprint and
Rowling then admitted that yes,
she actually did write the book.
Any questions about that one?
The next one is a
question that may come
up actually pretty often
when you're working
with researchers is, you may
want to explore the question,
what are themes common in
19th century literature?
Again, this question is
impossible because you need
to read a very large corpus
of 19th century literature
that's impossible
to do with human reading.
So Matt Jockers and David
Mimno explored this question
in their paper in
2012 and this is a--
and so it involves
recognition of thematic patterns
in the writing and then
comparative analysis.
So what they did, this
is their approach, they--
to explore the themes, they
ran large quantities of text
through a statistical algorithm
to discover what we call topics
and we're going to talk about
this a little later today.
But topic modeling, just to
talk about in this context,
is based on the idea that words
that co-occur are more likely
to be related about the same
thing so that co-occurring words
that the computer picks out
are represented as topics.
And so here's a visualization
of one of their results.
So it's a word cloud, like a
Wordle, that consists of a theme
that they identified
algorithmically.
So, this is one that's
labeled Female Fashion.
So we see gown, silk,
dress, lace, ribbon.
So these are words that tended
to co-occur across the corpus
of text that they
were analyzing.
And so through these results,
Jockers and Mimno were able
to argue that authors from
this time period wrote a lot
about what women wore
among other things.
So any questions about that?
And then the last
example that we looked
at was what textual
characteristics constitute
literary language?
And this was a good one for
looking at with text analysis
because it covers a very
large time span at looking
at a breadth of literature.
So it explores both change
over time as well as patterns.
And so Ted Underwood and Jordan
Sellers used classification
of algorithms to study what
characteristics constitute
literary language.
So what they did is
their approach is
to show the difference in
words used in poetry, drama,
and fiction with those
used nonfiction prose
to demonstrate how literary
language developed over time.
So they trained a
computational model
to recognize literary
genres, and then they compared
which words were most
frequently used over time
in nonfiction prose
versus literary genres.
And so these results that they
found demonstrated for poetry,
drama, and fiction a tendency to
start using older English words.
So again, here's
a visualization,
one of the visualizations
they have in their paper,
and it shows one way that
literary diction differs
from nonfiction writing between
1700 all the way to 1900.
So the y axis shows the ratio of
old words to new English words
and the x axis shows years.
And so the graph shows age
over time of the words.
And so the words in poetry,
drama, and fiction are
at the top in the purple line
and the nonfiction prose
is the lower line in gray.
And so the graph shows a
gradual increase in the use
of new words, both
categories until about 1775,
and then we see a divergence
with older words beginning
to be more prevalent in
poetry, drama, and fiction.
And so this analysis starts
to allow them to point
to certain patterns
in literary language.
So, next, we're going to talk a
little bit about the HathiTrust
and the HathiTrust Digital
Library and how they work
to support text analysis, and
again, talking a little bit
about the context we'll
be working in today.
So this is a diagram that shows
how the HathiTrust Digital
Library and the HathiTrust
Research Center are
in a basic text analysis
workflow.
So know-- and we'll talk
about this a bit more.
This is not a naturally
occurring workflow
but an optional approach that
a researcher can initiate.
And so we'll talk
a little bit more
about how text analysis is
actually quite nonlinear
and like this.
So, in a basic text
analysis workflow,
the researcher gathers digitized
text that's been scanned
and OCR-ed.
And OCR is optical
character recognition.
And then they apply
computational methods
to the text.
So as we saw in those examples,
they could do comparative
analysis, word counts,
all sorts of things to
start discerning patterns
in the work-- in the text.
And then they analyze the
results with those algorithms.
And where the HTRC, as we call
the HathiTrust Research Center,
enters in is it allows
researchers to gather text
at scale from the
HathiTrust Digital Library
and then it also-- the HTRC
also provides tools and services
that we'll work with
today that allow
to apply computational methods
and tools to those texts
from the HathiTrust
Digital Library.
And then again, the research
though at the bottom still has
to do their own analysis.
So, as much as we work
with the researchers
as US librarians work
with the researchers,
the researchers then has
to do their own analysis.
So, how many of you have heard
of the HathiTrust,
have worked with it?
Yes, everybody.
So, I'm not going to
belabor this point,
but just a very basic overview,
HathiTrust was founded in 2008
and it's a community
research libraries committed
to the long-term
curation and availability
of the cultural record
and it's an offshoot
of the Google Book
project and most
of the digitization has happened
at academic libraries
such as Uris.
And so currently, it's over
120 partner institutions
who are continuing to
contribute digitized material.
So, the HathiTrust Digital
Library is concerned
with the collecting,
preserving, and providing access
to this content from the
partner institutions.
It currently has over 60 million
volumes, about half in English,
and material going back
to the 15th century,
though the majority is
from the 20th century.
And so, because of
the concentration--
more of a concentration
in 20th century,
about 63% of the material is
in copyright or restricted
because right status
is known-- unknown.
And then the remaining 37% is
what you can search and read
on that-- through
that search interface.
But there's currently a
copyright review process
that a number of librarians,
some of your colleagues,
may be involved in to
determine right status
and then books are taken
or put into public domain
as they determine that.
And so-- And then
soon, very soon,
the HathiTrust Digital Library--
HathiTrust Research Center is
getting set up to provide access
to that in-copyright
text through a process
that we'll talk about
in a second,
non-consumptive research.
So, HathiTrust Research
Center is allow--
is on the other end
of HathiTrust in terms
of allowing researchers
to gather and analyze
and produce new knowledge
from the text
in the HathiTrust
Digital Library.
So, researchers can do large
scale computational research
through-- with HathiTrust text.
The center is co-located both--
and co-led by Indiana
University Bloomington
and the University of Illinois.
And both institutions do
a number of R&D projects
and user engagement
to enable researchers
to do large scale
computational research.
And so as I mentioned,
the HathiTrust Research
Center is getting ready
to provide access to
in-copyright text.
Both with the in-copyright
text as well
as the public domain text
that researchers do large
scale computational research,
we operate within
a non-consumptive
research paradigm.
So this is the formal definition
right here but basically,
it allows a person to run tools
or algorithms against the text
without actually
letting them read that.
And this is because it
complies with copyright law
because the researcher is
engaging with the ideas
of the works rather than
their specific expressions.
And so it's sometimes called
non-expressive use because of
that particular type
of engagement.
And so the non-consumptive
research protocol--
not protocol, but paradigm is
the foundational underlying
structure of how the HTRC
provides large scale access
to the HathiTrust works.
And so Eleanor actually
co-wrote a policy that goes
into further detail about
our non-consumptive research
approach and that's on the
HathiTrust website as well.
So, this is our outline for
the remaining part of the day.
And so, the outline of
the workshop is going to,
in a very basic sense,
follow the research process
of how a researcher might
conduct text analysis.
So, after this, the next two
modules that I'll take you
through will be about
gathering textual data
from both the HathiTrust
and then more generally.
And then we'll talk about
working with textual data
and doing data cleaning.
And then later, when
Eleanor takes over,
we'll talk about
analyzing textual data,
both again from the HathiTrust
and doing-- using Python.
And then we'll end the day
with visualizing textual data
and doing some data
visualization.
So in each module, we're going
to do hands-on activities
to think about how you would
approach a research question
from each of these stages
and we're, in particular,
going to use an example research
question and a case study
at each step of the
research process.
And again, we'll be using both
HathiTrust Research Center tools
and non-HTRC tools as well so
that you're getting a sense
of both HathiTrust, but also
more transferable skills
as well.
And so what our aim is, is
to really talk about the--
give you a sense of the
processes, the approaches,
and the tools that you can use
for engaging in text analysis.
So you'll hopefully leave
today with a better sense
of what is text analysis,
what's involved,
and how might it be used by
researchers on your campus.
So we're going to cover
both programming concepts
and computational methods
but you're not going
to be an expert coder
when you leave here.
You'll have some
tools in your toolbox.
And-- But this will provide
you kind of a jumping off point
that you can then go to other
workshops, other tutorials.
There's a wealth of resources
out there that'll
give you more nuances
that we won't be able cover
here in today's workshop.
And so we'll just give you
an introduction into things
to think about high-end
text analysis research.
So throughout the workshop,
we're going to return
to this sample reference
question for each stage.
So imagine that a
student comes to you
with this potential
research topic.
I'm a student in
history who would
like to incorporate digital
methods into my research.
I study American politics.
And in particular, I'd like
to examine how concepts
such as liberty change
over time.
So as we work in each
model throughout the day,
we're going to practice
different approaches
to answering this
reference question
with these different
types of tools.
And so this question hopefully
will also give you a better
sense of how the role
of a librarian can play
in helping the text
analysis research as well.
And then we're also
going to look
at throughout the workshop
a real-life case study.
And this is a real research
project that we worked
with in the HathiTrust
Research Center.
It is called the Creativity
Boom and it was conducted
by researcher Sam Franklin
who was at Brown at the time
as a doctoral student.
He's currently at
Stanford, I believe.
And he worked with the HTRC
to explore the use and meaning
of the words creative
and creativity throughout
the 20th century.
So throughout the
workshop today,
we're going to discuss how
this researcher approached this
question at each
stage of the process
and that can give us
a more concrete sense
of what somebody actually
did and considered
in doing their research project
in the text-- throughout--
for this text analysis project.
And if you want to see the full
abstract in much more detail
about the project, you can
follow that link on the Wiki--
to the Wiki-- HTRC Wiki.
And so, before we move on,
we also want to emphasize
and to start off the day
that our workshop module
and our outline may
just appear to suggest
that the research workflow
for our text analysis project is
linear and follows a very clean,
predetermined process
like this diagram
that somebody finds
text, prepares text,
applies the algorithms,
and then analyzes
and visualizes the results.
So, while we'll talk
about it in that context,
the reality is much
more like this.
So, an actual text analysis
workflow is quite complicated,
can be more complicated,
and it's rarely a linear
sequential process.
It's often more like
this diagram.
So depending on what the
researcher is trying to do
and the type of project, they
may search for some text,
they may find it, they may clean
it, but then they figure out,
oh, I need to get more.
They may do exploratory
visualization and that says, oh,
I need to get more text.
And they may go all the
way to preparing the text
for the final algorithm,
and still have to go back.
So there's a lot
of small cycles,
a lot of iterative steps.
So, again, while we're using
these modules as we're going
to talk about the text analysis
research process is a fairly
sequential process, things are
a lot messier in real life.
And then some of
you have experience
in those kinds of
projects as well.
OK. Welcome back, everyone.
It sounds like we had some great
discussions over the break.
OK. So we're going to get
started again and we're now--
the next two modules
are going to be talking
about accessing textual data.
And some of your comments
earlier highlighted some
of the challenges that
we're going to talk
about in a little
more depth right now.
So in addition to discussing the
variety of text data providers,
we'll talk about
building a corpus
from the HathiTrust
Digital Library
and then how do we
import it into HTRC
and that will be our
hands-on activity.
So, again, here's an outline
on what we'll be covering
in this next module.
We'll explore the options for
finding data for text analysis
and we'll also consider
the concept
of dataset for text analysis.
And then for our
hands-on activity,
we're going to build a workset,
what we call text dataset
as a workset from
the HathiTrust.
And we'll talk about
text as data as corpora,
which we'll talk about
a little bit more.
And then we'll talk
about the case study
and the reference
question and talk
about in the case study how
Sam built his Creativity Corpus
from HathiTrust volumes and
understand a little bit more
about real-world strategies
for doing data collection.
So by the end of this module,
where we're going to end
up is you will have created
a collection of volumes
from the HathiTrust Digital
Library and prepared it
for analytics in the
HTRC Analytics portal.
OK. So first, when we think
about collecting text as data,
this is a great quote that
we pulled from an article
by Thomas Padilla,
who's currently a visiting
digital research services
librarian at UNLV.
And he wrote about three common
challenges to getting text.
So first, the data of
interest has to be found
as we heard some
of our comments.
That can be a challenge.
Second, the data
must be gettable.
So again, how do we actually get
to that text data
if it's impossible?
And third, if it's
not already formed
to the perfect wildest
dreams type of format,
ways must be known of
getting that data into a state
that is really usable for the
desired computational methods
and tools.
So before any text analysis
can actually be conducted,
researchers need to find
that text data they need.
And the process is not always
as easy as it may seem.
And so today, in this next
module, in the next few minutes,
we're going to explore
ways of finding text.
So, there's plenty of
sources, as we've heard,
for getting text data for
analysis but suitable text
for computational analysis
is not always easy to get.
And so these are some of
the challenges that you
and researchers will encounter
in trying to get text data,
so one, copyright and
licensing restrictions.
So may that-- copyright
restrictions may prohibit users
from accessing or publishing
with that text data or storing
out on their own computers.
Another common issue, our texts
are often provided in formats
that require additional
processing before computational
analysis can even be conducted.
So, some documents are just
scanned images as we heard.
And they need to be OCR-ed
and made machine-readable
and cleaned before
text analysis.
And then another issue is
the systems themselves.
So the system may be hard for
the researchers to navigate
to get at that text data
and they might need higher-level
programming skills in order
to be able to grapple with those
database systems and get the--
pull the text out
of that system.
And additionally, some
issues may be easier to deal
with when you have just
a small amount of text,
if you're just trying
to get 10 volumes.
But when you think about larger
and larger corpora and working
up the scale, but when
researchers try to work
at that large scale, the
issues are magnified.
So, some things may not
be apparent until you try
to get that larger corpora.
But things are being under the
works to hopefully make some
of these challenges easier.
So, now we're going to talk
about some of the common types
of sources where users
can start looking
for textual data that they want.
So one source that's quite
common especially what
researchers see right
away are vendor databases.
So the databases that
we purchase and provide
to our researchers,
those are often a source
that people immediately point to
but often there are
licensing restrictions
because even though the
data that's provided is
of higher quality, agreements--
but the vendors prohibit
us from getting that data
to actually use for
text analysis rather
than just reading.
So there's often
prohibitions on storing
and publishing that data.
So there's a few strategies that
we suggest that can make that--
working with the
vendors easier, first,
the library can negotiate
addendums
to their licensing contracts
that allows researchers
to get access to the text
data and permit text analysis.
Some vendors are providing
services for text analysis.
So they're building
tools and services
for text mining their
collections.
Gale is building a tool, JSTOR
Data for Research, LexisNexis.
So some vendors do have
these services out there
but they can be expensive and
sometimes hard to work with.
And then in some cases, research
can ask for special permissions
to mine a specific portion
of the vendor-provided data
but sometimes that requires
fees as well for getting
that special permission
and getting the access
to store and publish the data.
And so one example is
JSTOR Data for Research
and that one is open
and available.
It provides limited
types of corpora
from the JSTOR collection.
So one is vendor.
And then digital collection.
So we've heard some of the
biggest digital collections,
the Biodiversity Heritage
Library, digitized newspapers
from Chronicling America.
So, those collections and
many, many more that we have
in our libraries have a wealth
of text data as we've heard.
But these data from libraries is
often siloed and not formulated
for research at scale.
And so when finding data
from digital collections,
there are two key things
that we suggest that you look
for that can make things easier.
First, make sure that it's
in accessible format,
often plain text.
Second, look for digital
collection content
that can allow for
bulk download as well.
And the University of North
Carolina's DocSouth Data is an
example of a digital collection
that's really great to be used
for text analysis because
they've made it in plain text
and they've made it
accessible for bulk download.
And there's many others
out there as well.
And then social media.
So social media platforms are an
additional source for text data
and research based on analysis
of social media data is getting
increasingly popular and useful.
So some social media
platforms do have systems
that allow access
to some of the data.
Twitter, in particular,
has an API
and there are some third
party tools available as well
that allow researchers
to plug in and get data.
So we-- at Illinois,
we had Crimson Hexagon
as one of those tools.
So there's many out there
that might be accessible.
So we're going to
talk a little bit more
about Twitter APIs
later but this is some--
the ability to get at social
media data is constantly
evolving as well.
So, let's talk a bit with
those qualifications in mind,
we'd like you to
consider, you know,
what would be the challenges
and weaknesses of trying
to use those different
sources if the student wanted
to a build a corpus
for political history?
So what will be the strengths
and weaknesses for each
of the sources of data for that
particular research question?
These are some of the
things that you want to talk
about with the researcher
as they're trying to figure
out what text data
they want to use.
So, do they have a
data source in mind?
It is digitized?
What's the period, place,
or person of interest?
So where is the framing?
And then how much
flexibility is needed
for working with that data?
Are there copyrighting and
licensing restrictions?
How experienced is
the researcher?
So they may need
programming skills
to get at some of that data?
Does the researcher
have funding?
So, as was mentioned,
ProQuest or Wiley may charge
for them to access that data.
And then what format does the
researcher expect it to be in?
So somebody raised
the issue of media.
So depending on what kind of
media formats they want to use,
do they want to just use text?
Or is it going to have to
be converted in a format?
Yeah. So these are just
some of the questions
that you might think
about as you're talking
with the researcher about
what type of data they need,
when they need it, et cetera.
So when you build a corpora,
there are several things--
the process that you do
is to build that corpora.
And so, as I've-- as we
mentioned, corpora are bodies
of text and that's just the
term that we use to talk
about the unstructured bodies of
text that you gather together.
So, the researcher starts
building their corpora first
by identifying text
and that's often done
through a full text search,
so finding the key term,
like creativity or key
phrase that's going
to start identifying
the types of text
that you'd be interested in.
And then depending on those
specific research questions
that somebody is using,
exploring, one can identify text
with metadata, so looking
for certain authors,
looking for a certain date
range, or even a specific genre.
And that gets into thinking
about how accurate
is the metadata
in identifying these texts.
And then often, it's a
combination of these two things
in terms of identifying the text
first in full text searching
and then looking through the
metadata to pick up things
that may have not had
immediate identifiers
through full text search.
So once the texts
have been identified,
the next step is
often deduplication,
which means getting rid
of multiples of volumes.
And so what to keep and what
to discard is really dependent
on the researcher as we'll
see in some examples.
So, some ways that a researcher
might do some deduplication
might be based on
the OCR quality.
So OCR quality can vary highly
from fairly dirty as we'll talk
about to highly, highly curated,
choosing the earliest edition,
editions without
forwords and afterwords.
Again, there's-- and we'll see
in Sam's project a little later
kind of all the different ways
that you can choose
to deduplicate.
And so now, we're going
to look-- we're going to--
in this module, we're
going to focus a bit more
on how the HTRC can allow
you to build text datasets
through the-- from the
HathiTrust Digital Library
collections and how you can
think about assisting users
in building up that text
corpora for analysis.
So the HTRC worksets are one way
that the HathiTrust allows users
to create text corpora
to analyze.
So what we call a workset
is basically a user-created
collection of text from the
HathiTrust Digital Library.
And so you can think of
them as textual datasets.
And so the idea behind
the workset is
that researchers can build
their own collections
which is something they're used
to doing in the analog world
through other means, through
long practices in humanities,
and then these worksets can be
cited and used by other users,
which helps ensure
reproducibility when we think
about research reproducibility,
and then people can test your
results using that same analysis
with that same collection.
And worksets are
often also suited
for non-consumptive
access which means
that users don't directly
consume the text themselves
but they run tools or algorithms
against that collection of text
for research analysis.
So when you view a
workset in HTRC Analytics,
you aren't seeing the text,
but you're seeing metadata
about the volumes that you've
gathered in that workset.
And so you can't read the text
in that interface on the left.
And then, at the
right, you see the--
what the workset is at
its core is a manifest.
So this is a manifest of the
HathiTrust Digital Library IDs
for each of those volumes.
So how are we going
to build worksets?
So, worksets are stored in
the HTRC Analytics system
and you'll need to create
an account which all
of you should have done tied
to your institutional
email address.
So you have to have a
user institutional address
and not Gmail or Yahoo
to soar your worksets.
And so there's two ways
to build your workset.
So you can create collections
with the HathiTrust Collection
Builder which we'll be using
and import from the
Collection Builder
into the analytics
portal or another way is
to compile the volume
IDs from that manifest,
compile them elsewhere, and
then upload it to Analytics
and it pools the workset based
on that upload of volume IDs.
We're going to do the
first method of importing
from the Collection Builder.
So, this-- again, here's our
sample reference question.
And what we want to do is
create a textual dataset
of volumes called-- that
the student might use
for their research
question and then import it
into HTRC Analytics
to do some analysis.
Now, so what I'm going to do is
I'll first demo this hands-on
activity and then we'll
allow you some time to kind
of just go dive in and do
it based on the handout.
So on page 5 and 6
are the directions
for this next activity
we'll be doing.
So what we're going to do
is we're going to login
to the digital library, create
a collection of volumes.
We're going to take a collection
from the public papers
of the president of the United
States because, let's say,
the student heard about that
collection and they're like,
I think these volumes
might be useful
for what I'd like to analyze.
So, how do we gather
a collection for them
of the public papers to the
president of the United States?
So, I'm going to demo that now
and then we'll have
time to then go in, so.
We'll switch to the
digital library.
And so what we'll do, we'll go
to the digital library
and I'll log in.
And if you're a HathiTrust
member, you should see your--
you should be able to
find your institution.
If not, you would
log in as a guest.
So I'll login.
OK. So we're going to go to
advanced full text search.
And we're going to use this
exact phrase, public papers
in the title and then this
exact phrase, United States.
And then search.
OK. So, we have-- So when
we build the workset,
the first thing we do is we
identify the volumes we want.
So, we click check, check box.
You can do individual
ones or you can go
up to the top and
just do select.
Let's say I want 100 per page
and then I can select
all on that page.
And then, I'm going to
create a new collection.
So I-- you can see I
have several collections,
but I'll create a new one and
I'll call this collection.
And then, you can add a
description if you want.
And then, you can make
it private or public.
Public if you have a very
highly curated workset.
But we'll leave it as private
so that only I can use it.
And then, I have a
collection created.
And then, I go to
my collections.
And I'm demoing this and
then we'll take some time
to go through it.
So, go to my collections.
You find the collection
that you just created.
So, I'll scroll down.
Here it is.
And then, you'll
download the TSV of the--
the metadata as a TSV format.
So, you download it.
Save it in a place
where you can find it,
some lines in my
downloads folder.
And then, you upload
it into analytics.
>> I know everything is on the--
>> Harriett Green: Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Oh, I'm going to--
I'm showing it
and then we'll have some
time for you to do it.
>> OK.
>> Harriett Green: Yeah.
So, I'm just going to-- just
showing to see how you do it.
And so once you do the
works-- Once you get into--
Once you download it,
you'll go into the worksets
and then you create a workset.
So, let's first-- And so then--
Well, and then I
upload it through here.
So, I will-- I'm just showing
kind of like the basic steps.
And then create.
OK. So, let's-- And then
I create the workset
and I have a workset.
OK. So, we're just kind of
show you how to do the process.
So now, we're going
to take a few minutes.
And if everybody wants to take--
go through the steps
and we'll circulate
and help you build your workset.
Now, we have the screenshots
actually for this as well both
as a backup and also when
you take these materials
and try to use them.
So, these are available
for doing that.
But just to review the steps
again for building the workset,
we went into the digital
library interface.
The core search, we logged in.
So, everybody should log in
with their institutional address
or their Google guest.
Then we all search for volumes.
And so, we use the advanced
full text search to search
for United States
and public papers.
So, that really narrowed
our workset
because as you may have searched
in HathiTrust Digital Library,
you can get thousands
of results very fast.
And then, we filtered the
volumes to see one thing
that was brought up in the
exercise that was good to note.
You need to select volumes
that are full text view.
So, that's the only way that the
algorithm currently will read
the workset as if you have
full text view volume.
So, that's something
to keep in mind
as you're filtering as well.
And then, we added
them the collection
by creating a new collection.
One thing to note about when
you create your collection name,
it has to have the characters
only A through Z, 0 through 9.
So you can't add
different characters.
So, keep that in mind as well.
So if somebody is creating a
collection and they have to--
they went into problems,
that's why.
And then, go to my
collections to view it.
And then, we clicked in
to view the collection.
And then, you want to
download the TSV file.
And then, we went into
analytics and logged in to that.
And then, we clicked on the
worksets from of the menu.
And then you should have
chosen Create a Workset.
And then you wanted to-- you
should've uploaded the TSV file
so that it could
read your workset.
And, again, keeping in mind
that your workset has to have A
through Z, 0 through 9 and
only selected characters,
and then you have
the created workset.
So, let's-- in our
closing minutes,
let's take a look
at what Sam did.
So, he searched across
the full text
of HathiTrust Digital
Library for creative,
that's the root of it.
And he wanted results
that either contained
creative of creativity.
So that's how he searched.
And then after the search, he
had an initial list of over 2--
of 2.7 million volumes.
But there were some
duplicate materials.
So, he decided the duplicates
he wanted to get rid off was--
have these different
editions of the same work,
but discard multiple
copies of the same edition.
So in that case as
Eleanor was mentioning,
three libraries may have
digitized the same edition
and it will add all three
if you don't identify
those same copies.
And so, again, different
rules for different projects.
So, Sam decided he
wanted different editions
but not the same edition.
Somebody else may want--
have a different criteria
for their project.
And the deduplication
was not done by hand
with over a million volumes, but
he used the metadata to filter
through and then filter out
those volumes he didn't want.
And now, we're going to go
straight into the other version,
other ways of gathering text
data for doing bulk retrieval.
So as some of the final
questions asked, what happens
when you want more than
a thousand volumes?
What happens when you need to
do larger scale text retrieval?
So now, we're going to
talk about some strategies
for doing web-- gathering text
from web in bulk using APIs
and doing file transfers
together text data.
So, this here is an
outline of what we'll cover
in the next 45 minutes.
We'll take a look at how
researchers can access data
in the automated way that allows
them to download text in bulk.
So, we're going to explore
like basic APR protocols.
So if you heard API and
you're a little scared of it,
don't worry, we're going
to break that down for you.
And then, we're going to do some
hands-on with the command line
and use wget which is a
fairly basic script program
to do web scraping.
And then at the end,
we'll conclude
by seeing how Sam gathered his
data for his Creativity Corpus.
So, where we're going to end up
is we're going to run command
from the command line
interface and we're going
to scrape text from a webpage.
OK. So for text analysis
projects, more--
most researchers will
need more than 10 texts.
They're going to be working
with hundreds, thousands
or even millions of texts.
And getting all this data
can be very time-intensive.
And so as people have pointed
out already just pointing
and clicking is pretty
inefficient.
So, it's really necessary
to automate data
gathering when possible.
So, we're going to walk about
in the next few minutes what are
some options for doing automated
data retrieval and we're going
to then practice some
basic web scraping.
So, one, there's a few--
three different ways in
particular we want to highlight
for how you automate
the retrieval of text.
And this is, again, especially
important when you're thinking
about large scale text analysis.
So, first, providers can
make their files available
through file transfer
mechanisms.
So, file transfer
protocol or FTP or SFTP,
if it's a secure file
transfer protocol,
are ways for moving especially
large files from one place
to another on the internet.
And then another way of
transferring files is rsync,
which is what the
HathiTrust uses.
And this is efficient because
it only sends the differences
between files from the source
location to the destination.
So, you run rsync
from the command line,
and this is what is used to
download extracted features data
which we'll work with
a bit later on today.
Another way to bulk retrieval
of text data content is
through web scraping,
which means as some
of you may have heard about,
grabbing text from the web.
So, there's lots of text
out there on the web
that could be used
for text analysis.
And web scraping helps
you avoid just copying
and pasting every
single web page.
So, there's a couple ways
to scrape text from the web.
You can run commands on the
command line which we're going
to talk about a little later.
And then you can write a script.
And a script is basically a
file that contains commands,
programming statements that
the computer will then follow
to then carry out those actions
and scrape the web
from the website.
And so, we're going to be using
scripts a little later on today
and some of our hands-on
activities,
but just to introduce
that concept.
And then, there's a
web scraping software.
So if you don't want to
write scripts, there's things
such as Beautiful Soup,
Web Scraper IO or Kimono
that do the work for you.
So, we're going to
come back to that.
But a few things before--
We're going to come back to
web scraping a little later.
But we wanted to
highlight a few things
that are just good citizen
practices when you decide
to do web scraping because
web scraping could put a large
workload on a server, and this
could upset the data holder,
if they're like why is somebody
trying to take down my website,
and you may be doing
that unintentionally.
So, you know, a lot of data
providers are more than willing
to share, but it's good to
just ask them, you know,
notify them that-- ask them
for access and check for an API
which is less intensive on
their website, and that's a way
that they provide
text data to you.
And if you still have to use web
scraping, if there is an API,
we suggest that you
time your requests.
And so, there's a delay
between the hits on the server.
So, this is not only
polite, but it also signifies
that you're a good citizen
and that you're doing
this not maliciously.
So, just kind of timing
those requests and make sure
that you're not taking
down the site.
Now, APIs, we're going to talk
a couple few minutes bout APIs.
So, this is another way to
automate the retrieval of text.
So, API stands for application
programming interfaces.
And so, APIs are basically
instructions written in code
for accessing systems
or collections
and they provide digital
pathways to and from content.
And so basically, for example
when you use the Amazon's API
you can display information
about the items or for sale
on Amazon or gather or items,
data about sites and items
not available for Amazon just
by using their API and
grabbing that data.
So, you might think of an
API like a mailbox and a key.
So, you open the door with the
key and then that allows you
to retrieve or deposit
items via that API.
So usually, you have
to write code
to retrieve content via APIs.
But some of them do have
graphical user interfaces what
we call GUIs that make that
process a little easier
and more consistent
and convenient.
So again, a number of
digital providers have APIs.
So, Amazon as I mentioned,
YouTube, a number of places,
a number of sites make
those APIs available,
Twitter which we've just--
we've mentioned earlier.
So, you can grab data, you
can grab a certain amount
of metadata and some
of them are limited.
So, Twitter can limit
the number of tweets
that you can then display
on a non-Twitter website.
But then, there's also things
like the Chronicling
America API.
So, our hosts do have
API that allow people
to gather the digitized
newspaper data.
So, there's a variety
of examples out there,
of ways that we can gather data
from both digital collections
as well as commercial
providers as well.
So, the HathiTrust does
have a bibliographic API.
And so access to some
APIs is available
through a publicly available URL
which is what HathiTrust does
for its bibliographic API.
And so, that's the kind we're
going to experiment today.
So, this API is primary
for retrieving bibliographic
metadata and volume data.
And so, there's other APIs for
gathering other types of data,
but this is one of the more
straightforward ones and--
to practice with.
And so, we use this
bibliographic API.
We're going to gather the
metadata using a specially
formatted URL plus
the volume ID number.
And so, we're going to talk
about, we're going to do
in this next activity,
a short activity
to gather a bibliographic
data through the bib API.
So, we're going to use--
So the hands-on activity
we're going to do.
And then, the instructions
are on page 7.
And this-- And I really
recommend you look
at the instructions because it
really lays out how to do this.
So, what we're going
to do is we're going
to search the HathiTrust for
a volume and then you're going
to click on the full or limited
search volume and then you want
to find the volume ID.
So, what we're going to
do, I'll demonstrate it.
And then, you're going to
use the URL in the format.
You should see a little
diagram, a little worksheet
that has the different spaces.
And so, you're going to
use that formatted URL,
and you should see
this on your handout.
You're going to use
this formatted URL
to retrieve the bibliographic
data using the HathiTrust
bib ID.
So, let me demonstrate that and
we'll walk through it together.
And then, we'll give
a couple minutes
for you to try on your own.
OK. So, what you want to do, so
let's say that we have public--
so, let's say I want to
retrieve the bibliographic data
for one of these volumes.
So, I click into the full
view, so I found this book.
And when you find the
book, everything from the--
you go to the URL, everything
from-- it says ID equals,
and then you see a code.
And the first few
letters are the code
for that digitizing institution.
And if you highlight everything
from that code to the semicolon,
that's the volume ID you want
for the HathiTrust
Digital Library.
So then, I'll go back.
So then if I go back-- And so,
each of you should see
this worksheet here
and you can write it.
So, I just want to
copy this format.
So, what you're going
to type in--
or you can copy this from the
materials you've downloaded.
You have catalog.hathitrust.org,
api/volumes.
The next step is
brief versus full,
so that will just say
how long the record is.
And then, we're going to put
here the ID type that I found
in that URL, and then .json.
So, I copy that from
here and open a new tab.
So, I'll delete that.
And so, here is the
first part, volumes.
And then, let's say
I want to a full.
And then, the ID
type would be htid.
And as you can see,
there's several types of ID.
We're just going
to use the htid,
but you could also use the
OCLC, the record number,
the library congress
number, catalog number.
So, there's several types of
volume ID that you could use.
So if I copy the URL and I
say full and then I use htid
and then I go back to
the book where I found it
and I'll copy this ID number
right here and then I paste
that in and then .json and I hit
enter, and then that is the API
for the bibliographic data.
Does that make sense?
So, let's take a couple minutes.
We'll circulate if
you want to try it.
And again, you might use that
worksheet to kind of fill in,
if you want to write down each
piece and then paste it all in.
So, we're going to move on to--
Again, this was the introduction
and there's much more out there
both on the HathiTrust API
that you're welcome
to read and delve into
or ask some questions.
But we're going to start and
dive into the command line
and do some web scraping now.
And so, this is Bash shell
in terminal on the Mac.
And so, we're going talk
about this a bit more,
but this is kind
of what it looks
like if you're on your computer.
So, what is the command line?
So, command line is a text-based
interface that takes in commands
and passes them to the
computer's operating system
to run and accomplish
a wide range of tasks.
So, the interfaces usually
implement what we call a shell.
So on a Mac, that shell
is called terminal,
and that is a Bash shell.
On Windows, it's command prompt.
It's not the same thing.
They do not speak
the same language.
So when we talk about a
Bash shell, we're talking
about a Unix-based shell.
So, Mac is default.
It's a default Unix system.
And so when you open terminal,
you already have a Bash shell.
For Windows, you want to
install GitBash or Cygwin.
Windows 10 does come
installed with a Bash shell.
But anything earlier than
that, you're going to have
to install another program.
And so avoiding-- In order to
avoid all these system issues,
because we see a variety
of computers out here,
we're using PythonAnywhere.
So, both to avoid the operating
system issues now and then also
for teaching in the future
PythonAnywhere works well
when you're trying to
teach workshops based
on our experience.
So, PythonAnywhere
is a browser-based
programming environment.
So, you can write code,
you can save the files
and also run it from-- and then
it all runs in your browser.
So, it comes with a Bash--
built-in Bash console that
we're going to be using
to run the commands,
and it doesn't interact
with your local file system.
So as we're going to see in
a few minutes and as you saw
in the setup, we have to upload
the files in order to be able
to run them and interact
with them via PythonAnywhere's
Bash shell.
So, just a couple basic tips
for working in the shell.
So first of all, a directory,
what it calls a directory
is essentially a folder.
So what you see on your folder
is actually the directory.
So when you-- And so when change
directories, it's like going
from the desktop and double
clicking on downloads.
Cases, spaces and
punctuation matter.
So if you get errors,
a lot of times,
it's because you've
forgotten a punctuation,
you've added a space
that shouldn't be there.
So, that's immediately the
first thing I always look
at if something is not working.
And then hitting tab on--
when you're in the command
line will autocomplete.
So if you start typing the
name of a file and you hit tab,
it will say, oh yeah, that
file is in the directory,
I'll just autocomplete it.
So, that's pretty handy.
And also when you have long
filenames, as you're going
to see, there are some
files that we're using
that has super long numbers
and you can just start
and just tab through.
And then hitting in
the up arrow will cycle
through the last
command you entered.
So again, if you get an error
message, instead of having
to type in the entire script
all over again, just hit the
up arrow and then you can go
back and correct that command.
And then when you view
files in the shell,
you have to quit
before viewing command.
And so, use quit, q, to
quit viewing the file.
So, we have a video created
by our graduate assistant
Roja [assumed spelling]
that provides a nice
introduction
to the command line.
And this is also linked from
our project website as well.
Why there's no volume?
OK. Well, we may--
I think we forgot to
set up the speakers.
So in the interest
of time, we'll--
we have the backup slides that
kind of go through the steps
that she takes us through.
So, the Roja's video takes you
through the basic steps,
but we have it here.
So if you look on your
handout on page 8,
you'll see the commands
that she takes us
through at the bottom
of the page.
So, pwd allows you to see
your current directory.
And then, mkdir allows you
to create a new directory
or create a new folder.
Cd is to change the
directory, so to go up and down
into different folders.
Ls allows you to list the
files in your directory.
And then, mv allows
you to rename the file,
you type in less then
allow you to view the file.
And then-- Let's see.
And then, the other to touch
tells you to create a new file.
So, these are some of the
immediate-- these are--
this gives you kind
of a chi-chi.
But, let's-- In that case,
let's just go to PythonAnywhere
and start and we'll do some--
and go through some
of these basics.
So, if everybody wants
to go into PythonAnywhere
and we'll walk through this.
And then everybody should be
logged in for the free account.
OK. So, the consoles is where
you start your Bash file.
So, let's click on consoles.
And you may see this.
It says you have no consoles.
So, we want to click on Bash
to start a new console in Bash.
So, has everybody
opened the Bash shell?
All right.
So, you type in p-- So
following the steps on page 8,
we type in pwd, that
tells us where we're at.
So, that's-- If you start
getting lost, you're not sure
where you're at, pwd, so this
shows in my home directory.
And then if you type ls,
you see all the files.
So, you may not see
anything at the moment.
Well, you should see the
activity files dot zip,
does everybody see that?
Yeah. OK.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes. So then you see everything.
OK. So, the first thing
we're going to do is
that activity underscore
files dot zip,
we're going to unzip that.
I don't have it here.
So what-- if you haven't
already, when you go to files,
you should see a list of files
and you see the activity
files dot zip uploaded here.
So, I'm going to upload it.
So once you make sure that you
have the activity files dot zip,
we'll go back to the
console and then just type
in unzip activity files dot zip.
And then the next step, if you
see step 3 is mv activity files.
So, you want to move-- In order
to do the activities we're going
to be doing, you
want to move them.
So, I'll do mv activity files
and then space home hegreen.
So, is everybody able
to complete this,
to unzip the files
and move them?
Great. And as I showed,
punctuation matters.
So, make sure the
punctuation is correct.
And then if you do ls, you
should see these files.
Does everybody see these files?
So after you've done
the previous steps,
when you type ls, you
should now see those files
in your directory.
Are we good?
OK. So, web scraping.
So, we're going to use
the command line to--
tool wget, and this
helps you transfer files
from the web server by doing--
which is otherwise
known as web scraping.
So, it also can follow links on
the page and follow content too.
So, how you-- depending on
how you write the wget script,
it can follow just one level of
links or it can go three levels
down and scrape all the pages
underneath those links as well.
So, you do-- you specify that
kind of option and other options
through the flagged letters
that you put in the wget.
And so, options for a wget
include -l, that tells how far
in the hierarchy of
links you want to go.
And then limit rate sets
that transfer speed.
So as I mentioned earlier, being
a good citizen and not hitting
that web server constantly,
the limit rate dictates how
fast you hit the web server.
And so the script, the
script that we use--
we're going to use today
will have all those options,
and we'll see in a
second how that works.
So, we're going to return to
our sample reference question.
And so, the students wind
to analyze how concepts
such as liberty change
over time.
And so, one possible approach
that the student might use
to gathering data in addition
to the HathiTrust is maybe
to scrape some political
speeches from an open source.
So, we're going to
use WikiSource
to start building their corpus
and scrape some text from there.
So in this activity
we're going to do now,
we're going to run a wget
command to scrape text
from the open WikiSource version
of George Washington's Fourth
State of the Union Address.
So, we have the website
source here.
If you have the slides
or the handout open,
this is where you can-- you
can copy the website address.
We highly recommend
that you copy it.
But let's take a look at it.
So, here's the WikiSource page
that we're going to scrape.
So, you can see there's
lots of text, there's lots
of different links, et cetera.
So, what you're going
to need, you're going
to have your PythonAnywhere
open again.
We're going to use
the Bash shell
that we were just working
in, the website URL.
Again, I recommend you
copy it from the handout
or from the command itself.
And then, we're going to
use this wget command.
And again, this is
something you can copy
from the handout or slides.
So, let's look at
that w-- that command.
So, here's the source.
And so, we're going to use
this command, and I recommend
that you copy this or you
can carefully type it.
So, here's the command.
So, we have wget
and then -l space 1.
And so, that means that it's
only going to go one level.
It's not going to follow
links too far down.
And then -- limit rate means
that we're doing a speed of 20k,
and 20k is about a thoughtful--
it's pretty thoughtful speed.
We're not hitting
the server too much.
And then, we give the URL
for what we're scraping.
So as Amanda and Eleanor just
said, actually it's better
to follow the link or Google
the Fourth State of the Union
and copy the web
address from there.
And then output, dash-- so --
output document washington
underscore 4 dot txt,
that means we want it to write
what it grabs from the website.
We want it to put in a new
file called Washington 4.
So otherwise, the
command is going
to name it something that's
going to be based on that URL.
So, we're just going to keep
things concise and tell them--
tell the command put it in
this Washington 4 document.
OK. So, we go to
the Bash command.
So, we're going to wget
-l 1 -- limit rate=20k.
And then, I'll go to the
website, copy the URL,
paste it in, and then --
output-document=washington.
And actually, I think I
already have a Washington 4.
So, I'm just going to
do Washington speech.
And then I hit enter.
OK. So, let me actually
copy the URL that works.
OK. So everybody, when
you scrape the text,
you should see this
kind of screen.
It connects to the server.
So once you have the
text saved to your files,
so there's two ways that
you can view that file.
You can either go
back into your files.
And you have this
super zoomed in.
Go back into your files.
Find the washington underscore
4 and see-- if you see that,
that means it's scraped.
So, there it is.
And this is what's been
scraped from the web page.
And you can see,
there's a lot in there
that we may or may not want.
And then, I'll turn the
other way, is to go back
into our Bash console.
[ Inaudible ]
The-- There's a menu up here.
>> Oh.
>> Harriett Green: Yeah.
So, the PythonAnywhere menu
up here lets you
move back and forth.
So, I'd hit control l to
clear my screen again.
And then I have to
do less washington--
what was it, do less
washington 4.txt.
I can view the file in
the Bash console itself.
And then, I hit quit to
get out of the viewing.
So, I hit q and it takes me
back to the Bash console.
[ Inaudible ]
So, you're looking-- what
you're looking at is the--
all the text plus the HTML code.
>> All the tags?
>> Harriett Green:
Yeah, with the HTML tags
as well as the text itself.
[ Inaudible ]
Right. Right.
But this time, we scraped
it onto our own computer
for ourselves, exactly.
[ Inaudible ]
Right. Yeah.
Yeah. This is something
that you would--
especially if you're doing
a multiple files at once.
So, let's talk about--
So, what happened?
So as we-- as somebody
just asked,
we executed the wget
command and it scraped
from that web page using the
URL that we pointed it to
and it grabbed everything
on that page.
So, not just the text that
we were reading, but under--
everything underlying it
underneath because we told it
to go to the server
and just grab it.
So, what do you think is going
to be removed from this file
to prepare it for data analysis?
Because that's the next step,
is preparing this for analysis.
There's a lot of excess headers
and footers that we might want
to get rid off before
we actually make it.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes. Everything--
That's a good point
for what we're going to do next.
Great. That's the key.
Any other thoughts?
So, we're almost at lunch.
So just to wrap up.
So, we did this.
So, there's other options
that you could use.
So, this was a very-- wget
is a fairly basic command
that we can run, but
there's many other options.
So Beautiful Soup, it's a
Python-based web scraping tool.
It's very powerful.
A lot of researchers use it.
I've had researchers
come up to me and say,
I want to use Beautiful Soup.
And then I'm like teaching
myself Beautiful Soup right now.
So, there's-- that's one option.
Also, you can write web
scraping commands into a script.
So, a script is a
list of directions
for your computer to follow.
And so, we're going
to-- And after lunch,
we're going to use
some Python scripts
to do some text analysis.
But a script lets you iterate
through more content
and do it in bulk.
So, we just ran this
for one specific URL.
But if you have 100 web pages
that you need to scrape,
you don't want to write wget
for every single one of those.
So, a script will let
you do that in bulk.
And then again, make sure
when you do web scraping
to time your requests so that
you aren't hitting somebody's
web server heavily.
And so-- So, you're
being polite.
So, creating work sets is just
one way working with text data
in the HathiTrust
which we talked
about earlier this morning.
So, you could also download data
from the HathiTrust and HTRC
to work on your own machines.
And this chart gives
you overview
of all the different ways
that you can work
with HathiTrust data.
So, you can do a custom data
request and get bulk access
to the page images
and OCR of the--
texts that are in public domain.
And the researcher can
use abstracted text,
which we'll talk about
after lunch as well.
You can use the extracted
features
which are per volume
files, select metadata
and data contents and you get
JSON files of the selected data
such as word counts and
metadata about those volumes.
And then very advanced
researchers can use the public
domain-- access public domain
HTRC data through the data API,
which is used through
a special environment
that we call the data capsule.
So, the data capsule is
for advanced researchers,
and it's not great for
our workshop environment.
It's more for individual
projects.
So, we won't be mentioning
it in this workshop.
We're going through it,
but we want to mention
that as an advance.
And so both the custom
data request
and extractive features
are retrieved
through those file
transfer methods.
So, there's no user interface.
So, use FTP, rsync
to retrieve those.
OK. So to wrap up, let's
look at what Sam did.
So after creating a
final list of volumes
from the digital
library, he used rsync
to retrieve an extracted
features dataset from the HTRC.
And again, rsync is a
command line utility
that transfer the files between
his computers and the others.
And so really quickly, just
to say what is this
extracted features dataset
that we've been mentioning.
So again, it's JSON files for
each volume from the HathiTrust
that researchers can download,
and it has both metadata,
bibliographic metadata as
well as inferred metadata
such as page numbering, page
counts, word counts and more
that we'll talk about in
a bit more detail later.
So, this is something
that we encourage--
we don't quite have the
time now to go through it.
But some of you have
mentioned how do we think
about our digital
collections as text data?
So, the Santa Barbara Statement
on Collections as Data came
out of the Collections
as Data National Forum
which was an IMLS-funded
forum last year.
So at that link, you can
read their statement.
And it provides a set
of high level principles
to guide collections
as data work.
And they just received
another phase of that
from the Mellon Foundation to
do some more work in this area.
So, this is something that
we encourage you to reflect
on as we think about making our
own digital collections ready,
available for researchers
as text data.
And so, these are just some
of the highlighted principles
that you might consider.
And principle 2 of
the statement says,
collections as data
developments aims
to encourage computational
use of digitized
and born digital collections.
So, we think about what
are the textual documents,
what are the types of works
in our digital collections,
you know, what can we do to
encourage computational use.
Our host right here, the Library
of Congress is doing
immense work with the LC Lab.
So, I encourage all of you to
really look at all the resources
that they've made available
for accessing their collections
and actually some great
IPython notebooks even how
to work with the data.
It's really great.
>> Eleanor Dickson: So
through the afternoon,
we're going to be talking
about working with text data,
then we'll finally get to the
analyzing text data piece.
So, this is your text
analysis workshop, right?
And then at the very end, we'll
sort of expand or contract based
on time module on
visualizing text data.
And if we don't quite hit that
last module, we've recorded it
and you could always watch it
later if you're interested.
But I'm hopeful today
about our timing.
All right.
So in this module,
we're in Module 3
of the curriculum we're using.
We're going to be thinking about
what happens when text is data.
We'll talk about common
steps for cleaning
and preparing text data,
thinking about how you
might make recommendations
for researchers about how
to get their text data
ready for analysis.
We'll practice a bit of data
cleaning on the speeches
that you scraped earlier.
And then, we'll come back
to Sam and see what he did
with his Creativity Corpus
to get it ready for analysis.
So, this is where we'll end up.
I know it sort of
looks like both look
like blank text on white boxes.
But in one, if you
squint, you can maybe see
that in the top left corner,
there are still the HTML tags.
In the bottom right,
we've taken them out.
So, we're going to practice
running a Python script
to get that data cleaned up.
All right.
But first, let's talk
about humanities data.
So, I work at the
University of Illinois.
Illinois likes to
think about data
as material that's generated
or collected while
conducting research.
So, that's an expansive
definition.
And when we're thinking
about humanities data,
we might be thinking about
things like citations,
code or algorithms, databases,
geospatial coordinates.
Can anybody think of
any other kinds of data
that might be humanities data?
Yeah?
>> Text.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Text.
Yeah. You know, it's amazing
how many people don't offer
that as an answer
in this workshop.
So yeah, text data, right?
That's what we're here for.
What else?
Yeah. Go ahead.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, images.
Great.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, recordings, oral
histories in particular.
Anything else?
>> Transcriptions.
>> Eleanor Dickson:
Transcriptions, yup.
That's all great.
So when we start to think about
text as data, we often have
to shift the way that
we are approaching text
as we commonly think about it.
So, you might not think about
data quality necessarily
when you're reading say a
novel unless you spill coffee
on your library book, right?
But in this case, we want
to think about the quality
of the data that we're
going to use for analysis.
So, OCR can be both
clean or dirty.
Are you familiar
with those terms?
So yeah, this is a basic term,
clean OCR, someone has gone
through and then corrections,
dirty OCR has had no corrections
on or minimal corrections.
So, how to you address OCR
is dirty, it's uncorrected.
And part of that has to do
with how large the corpus is.
It would take a lot to clean
up over 16 million volumes.
And also the active cleaning
which I hope that you'll see
as we go through this module
is individually driven.
Every researcher, every
person has an idea
of what it would mean
to remediate their data.
And so, we don't want to
make any choices to the OCR
that would then make it
more difficult for somebody
to actually get out the
information they were hoping
to get.
When we think about text as
data, we also start to think
about the corpus or the corpora.
So, a text corpus is
a digital collection
or an individual's text dataset.
And then, corpora
are bodies of text.
So, that's just the plural.
And another nice way that
you can think about text
as data is thinking about
the way that the text
when you're getting ready
to analyze it might go
through the process of
decomposition or recomposition.
And these are terms that we
borrow from Jeffrey Rockwell.
So, cleaning can
involve discarding data
which can be like decomposition.
So, maybe you're getting
rid of elements that were
on the page or certain words.
And you're getting past what
was human readable to something
that a computer can
do something with.
And so oftentimes, the
prepared text might be illegible
and that you-- you know,
you could sit and read say
that JSON file that we looked
at earlier with the metadata.
But it's not legible
in terms of something
that you would enjoy
sitting down to read
on the weekend for fun.
So, a researcher goes about
the process of preparing data.
They'll do things like
correct OCR errors.
They may remove text
from the page object
like titles or page headers.
Can anyone think why
that would be important
to remove the page header?
Yeah?
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. Yeah.
It doesn't tell us much to
know that Moby-Dick is--
those are the two most
frequently occurring words
in Moby-Dick, right?
We aren't learning anything
more about what the--
about what Melville was saying.
Removing tags, that's the
one we're going to practice.
You might split or combine
files, remove certain words
or punctuation marks, lowercase
text or tokenize words.
And we're going to
look at some of these
in more detail in a second.
All right.
So, just really drive
home these key concepts.
Oftentimes when we're
thinking about how we're going
to prepare text, we can
think about it in terms
of chunking and then
recombining.
So first, thinking
about chunking the text,
which is the idea that
you would split the text
into smaller pieces.
And so often, it's going
beyond the book or the volume
as an object and breaking
it into smaller pieces
that have some importance
to the research question.
So, let's say somebody wanted to
do a comparative analysis of all
of the speeches of
Abraham Lincoln
and maybe there was one book
that was published of all
of those speeches and then
the researcher is going to go
through and break that text file
that represents this book object
into smaller pieces one
file for every speech.
So, they're chunking it up.
So, they can do that
comparative work.
Other times, we're thinking
about grouping text.
Maybe you're going
out to WikiSource
and you're grabbing all of
the George Washington speeches
that you can find there and
you end up with these files
that you scraped from
the web and you're going
to concatenate them together
to make one big file
that's all George Washington
so you could compare
that to Abraham Lincoln.
The important thing here
is that you really have
to go beyond thinking about the
volume, the book, the periodical
as a discrete object
that is based--
the most important
meaning, right?
You might want to break
it up into pieces.
You might want to smash it
together with something else.
So, you're sort of
taking that next step.
Another key concept
that we want to talk
about here is tokenization.
So, tokenization is the idea
that you're going to break text
into pieces that
are called tokens.
And the process of doing this
will discard punctuation marks.
I mean, often there are some
normalization that happens also
where maybe the text
becomes lowercase.
So here, we have the beginning
of the Gettysburg Address
and you can see that--
you can read it.
It's human readable, but it's
not human readable in a sense
that this isn't how you would
sit down to read the speech.
And every one of the
words has been broken
out into an individual
chunk where, you know,
we're seeing the notation
with the brackets.
And then now, because
this process has happened,
this doesn't-- this isn't
a human editing process,
this is a computer-generated
process, tokenize the text.
We have these chunks that
you can start to count up.
So, this is that--
a bit about reducing
and abstracting the text.
All right.
So, it's important
also to keep in mind
that data preparation is going
to affect the results
of analysis.
So the amount of text, the size
of the chunks will
impact what you get
out of a text analysis algorithm
which stop words are removed
will also have an impact,
which characters are
included or taken out,
whether the text is lower--
put into lowercase or
otherwise normalized.
I mean-- And this
process takes time.
This is often considered
to be one
of the most time-intensive
pieces
of doing data analysis
is this sort of--
I don't like this term, but sort
of data janitorial work,
right, data munging.
This takes a lot of effort to
get everything ready for you
to put it in for your analysis.
And this is where
running some kind
of scripting process
becomes useful.
So, you don't want this to
turn into an editing process.
And I think for some,
there is the temptation
to think I'm going
to get my text ready.
And there is a point at which
I have gone through in red,
you know, all of my volumes
and I've lowercased everything
and everything is
spelled perfectly.
And while that temptation is
there, it's up to the researcher
to decide how much noise they're
willing to accept in their data.
And some level of noise is
generally accepted to be OK.
But it's up to the researcher to
figure out what that level is.
Yeah?
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. So normalizing words,
think about if you were doing a
study of 19th century literature
and you had some works that
were written by American authors
and some by British authors
and they used two different
spellings for words like color.
You have to make the choice,
do I want to leave the spelling
difference there or do I want
to say that every time the text
has color, you normalize it
to either O-R or O-U-R.
Yeah. Any other questions?
That's a great one.
OK. So in your small groups, you
are going to read definitions
for some of these data
preparation terms.
So, there are seven of them.
And so, divide them
amongst yourselves.
You'll each read two or three.
And then when you finish
reading, you're going
to explain what you read to your
group mates, to your partners.
These definitions are taken
from a paper that was written
by Denny and Spirling in 2017.
And I quite like
this paper actually.
I say this in every
workshop that we do,
but I think this is a fun read.
So if you're interested
in learning more,
I would recommend going back
and reading the paper
that they wrote.
But we'll give you about five
minutes to take the time to read
through these and then
discuss them in small groups.
All right.
How is it going?
Did you all get through
all of them?
OK. Did you have any questions
about the terms that you read?
Any thoughts about these-- about
the terms that you went through?
Yeah. Go ahead.
[ Inaudible ]
You mean if you--
Yeah. So, you could choose not
to lowercase all of your text
if you think, oh, this
is chockfull of names
that I think would create
disambiguation problems
if I did lowercase
normalization.
But you can also do a part
of speech tagging before
you start your analysis.
So then, we're going to look
at a dataset example later
this afternoon where all
of the tokens have been put
through part of speech tagging.
So, that's another way to figure
out when you mean a rose
is a rose is a rose.
Yeah. But it-- In some of these
instances, you would choose not
to do the thing that you think
would cause an issue for you say
for the-- one about the numbers
with the sections of US code.
In that example, those
researchers might choose
to leave numbers in whereas
other researchers might take
them out.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I saw a hand in the back.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. I think that's sort
of like a subject
expertise question.
So, that's know your data,
know your research
question kind of thing.
If you think it would be really
important in your dataset
because of the nature, the
materials you're looking
at to keep United
States together,
then the researcher would
set that at the outset.
But I've never seen an
engram list like that.
Yeah. Do you have a question?
[ Inaudible ]
Well, so for some algorithms
like-- and frequently terms,
what you're trying to study
has more to do with the terms
that were used frequently.
And so, you just don't really
need to have to them there
in order to do the work.
And so, taking them out can make
sure that you're looking at data
that you think is
meaningful in some way.
So, size is one piece,
but also this is one step
of setting the scope
of your research.
And when we look at Sam
later, we're going to see some
of the tokens that
he got rid of.
And this is sort of what
goes in, what comes--
what goes in is what will
come out sort of thing
because you could-- especially
with things like stop words,
you could get really sort of
red penny with your stop words
and go through and just
start taking things out.
And suddenly, you're
going to have topic models
that have only certain
words displayed.
So, it's a balancing act
about trying to make sure
that the results are-- you
feel are somehow meaningful
and representative, but also
that you have not pushed
in such a way that
you're just getting
out what you wanted
to get out of it.
It's a balancing act.
>> So [inaudible]
elsewhere is to try
to always have a baseline
text that stays the same?
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes.
Yeah.
>> [Inaudible] to
talk about that,
but any of these
changes it can make,
that would be on top like--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes.
Yeah.
>> -- baseline text figured out
and then you would remove
things or add things--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes.
Yeah.
>> -- on top in a
different version.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes.
Yeah. We-- You know, we don't
talk about that, but we should
because it comes up regularly.
And sometimes, we have people
who are confused like, oh,
if you'd get rid of all words,
then you've made, you know,
these changes that you can't
go back, but-- you're right.
You want to do this
in separate versions.
So then if you do run an
analysis where you say you take
out certain kinds of stop words
and it doesn't look quite right,
then you just go back
to the earlier version
and you make some other
modifications and you try again.
Yeah. So, this-- it's not like
these are permanent changes.
This is sort of building on top
and you can always go
back and try again.
It's definitely an
iterative process.
Yeah. Any other thoughts
or questions?
All right.
How many of you have experience
with Python programming
or programming generally?
Awesome. OK.
Well, this actually is--
you guys are an experienced
crowd, so-- which is great.
So, just as a reminder, yeah, we
don't intend the Python portion
of the program to prepare you to
go out and write your own code
or to be an expert
developer, but we just want you
to feel more comfortable within.
If you already feel
really comfortable,
then this might be a good
time for you to lean over
and help your neighbor if they
need a little bit more help
getting through the activities.
OK. So, we start with an
introduction to Python.
So, what is Python?
So, Python is a scripting
language,
and it's also an
interpreted language.
And if you try to look up on
the internet what is Python,
often the definition you find is
it is an interpreted language.
And I don't know about you,
but that means literarily
nothing to me.
But what interpreted means is
that it follows step-by-step
directions.
So, what we're going to be
doing is running a Python script
which is a series of
step-by-step instructions
that your computer
is going to follow
in order to complete a task.
And so, the task today is going
to be things like we're going
to take out the tags, we're
going to remove stop words,
but the script is just
a list of directions
that your computer follows.
And Python has a relatively
straightforward syntax.
This is something that
the Python community feels
good about.
They call-- You know,
we're Pythonic.
So, I don't know if any of you
have used SQL where you're used
to having the semicolon
at the end of the line.
That's not a thing
they do in Python.
But what that means is if
you pick up a Python script
and you have some idea
of what you're looking at
and also the person has
well documented their code,
it's not too hard to get a
feel for what's happening.
Whether you could write it on
your own is another question,
but it's sort of like, I
see they have this thing
and it's going to do that thing,
I sort of understand
what's happening.
So, that's one of the benefits
of talking about Python today.
All right.
So, there are a few
different ways
that one would interact
with Python.
I'm-- We're going to mention two
and then I'll throw out a third,
but we're going to
use just one of those.
So, we mention this
first one because one
of you will invariably open up
the Bash shell, type in Python
and hit enter and then you're
going to see these three carets
and you're going to go, huh,
what am I supposed to do now?
That means when you type in
Python and then hit enter,
you are running what's called
the Python interpreter.
So, you're doing
interactive programming,
which means that the computer or
these three carets are like, OK,
give me a Python command to
enter, give me a little bit
of Python for me to do.
And so, you do it line
by line or step by step.
Remember, it's just
step-by-step directions.
So, this is one way to get
experience with Python is
to practice in the interpreter.
But you can see where this
would become not useful
if you say wanted a nice file
that you could reuse over
and over again and you don't
want to type out the directions.
So, this-- we're not
doing this today.
But if you do type in Python
and then you see the carets --
yeah, there are three,
sorry, just--
well, maybe there's actually
four, but there's three.
OK. You're going to type in quit
and then open parens
close parens.
That's how you get out of there.
All right.
But you're not going to
because we did the warning.
OK. So, the way that we are
going to use Python today is
by running scripts
that have been written.
So, scripts again are
just lists of directions
that your computer
is going to follow.
You save the file where the
script is written in a format
that has .py at the end.
So, this is a Python script that
you can execute, you can run,
and then it will open the file
and follow the directions.
And then, we're going
to be running these
from the command line.
So on the command line,
you'll enter in Python
and then the name of the file
and maybe some additional
directions
and then you'll run it that way.
Another way that we could
teach this workshop is
by using Jupyter Notebooks.
And I know-- or I think that
there are nice Jupyter Notebooks
for some of the LC Labs work
that they have been doing.
And if you're just
starting out with Python,
and you're like totally blank
mind in terms of where to go
from here, you might
actually want to start
with Jupyter Notebooks because
what it does is it takes the
script, so each of those
step-by-step directions.
And it's a way of rendering it
so that you can have
narrative before and after
and it's embedding
it in a viewer
that I think is much more
friendly for the beginner
to understand what's happening.
It's a little-- It's like the
interactive programming meets
the running of the
file in this way.
So, it's a nice combination
of the two.
All right.
So when you want to run a Python
script from the command line,
the first thing that you
have to type in is Python.
So, you have to tell
the computer,
I'm about to give
you directions,
they're in a certain language
and this language is Python.
And then you give
the script name.
And then at the end,
you include arguments.
So, these arguments are
some additional directions
that the script needs to run.
And in the script itself,
it will say whether
or not it requires arguments
and it will number
how many there are
and give some idea
for what those are.
And we're going to look
in a second about--
to see what that looks
like in practice.
So, tell the computer,
get ready,
I'm going to give you some
Python, direct it to which file
to open and run and
then there may be this
additional information.
All right.
So, let's return to our
sample research question.
And we are going to use a Python
script to prepare the text data
that we scraped from WikiSource.
All right.
So, we're going to remove
the tags, blah, blah, blah.
You need the Bash console.
So, you might want to start
pulling up PythonAnywhere
and get your console ready.
We're going to be running it
over the washington
underscore 4 dot txt.
And the name of the
script we're going
to be using is remove
tag dot py.
All right.
So, I'm going to move
into PythonAnywhere.
Did we talk about control l?
If your shell looks
really ugly, do control l
and it will remove-- sort
of like start you afresh.
But you can still arrow
through your preview commands.
They didn't disappear.
They just are gone
from your view.
All right.
So, let's take a look at the
file that we're going to run.
So, we're doing a
remove tag dot py.
So, you'll see at the
top that we're doing--
we have these import statements.
We'll talk more about
that later.
And then you'll see
that there's a line.
So we have this line in
green, that's a comment.
The green is a comment.
The computer doesn't read that.
It skips over.
But it's for you, the human,
to understand what's happening.
And it says requires
an input file name
when running this script.
So we have, yeah, done an OK
job of documenting the process
of what's happening here.
And you'll see that
there's sys.argv and then 1.
So, this script requires one
argument in order to run.
And the point of
the argument here is
that they want the user
who's running the command
to supply some additional
information
so that you could pop
in different files,
different text files
and run the same script
over a different text file.
OK. So if you have this open,
you're going to just want
to close it and go back
to your Bash console.
All right.
And so, we're just going to do
the first step all together.
So, what is the first thing
that we need to type in?
>> Python.
>> But don't have return.
And then, what's the next
thing that we need to type in?
>> Remove tags.
>> Remove tags, yup.
And I'm exceptionally lazy.
So, I'm using my tab.
So I have to type as
little as possible.
And then, what's the last
thing I need to type in?
[ Inaudible ]
The name of the script.
Yup. And I have several of them.
And I didn't get an error.
So now, I'm going to
view the file using less.
Oh, sorry.
We rename the file.
Look. I didn't read
the directions well.
So we see here-- This
is probably too small
for you, isn't it?
Is that better for viewing?
We see here that we're opening a
file called tagless file dot txt
and we're writing to it.
So, can you see how this is--
I mean, it's not like easy,
but it's also like, OK,
I can understand
something is getting opened
and something is
getting written, right?
So, we're opening a file
and we're writing to it.
So when I try to do the less
command here, I did it wrong
because I was trying
to look at Washington.
But we didn't actually-- As we
discussed a few minutes ago,
we didn't overwrite
anything on Washington 4.
We created a new file that
doesn't have any tags.
So, I want to do
tagless file dot txt.
So, you should all
have this file now.
Maybe you should be able to see
that the tags have
been stripped out.
So remember, you can put
[inaudible] up if you get stuck.
If you have gone through
this, try to do the activity
at the bottom of the page 13.
So, can you remove
the stop words?
All right.
So if you're an experienced
Python person,
you probably don't feel too
proud of yourself right now.
But if that's the first time you
have ever run a Python script,
congratulations,
it was less scary
that you might have thought
it was going to be, right?
It's just like entering
the commands
that we did earlier except
that we're running the
commands over these files.
OK. So-- And we had
someone point
out that we think
there's something wrong
because we didn't remove the
tag at the end, right, which,
it points out a pitfall of
taking somebody else's code
and trying it on
your own materials.
You want to-- You know, there's
going to be a process of trying
to make it fit for
what you want to do
or correcting a mistake
that they made.
OK. We skip this,
blah, blah, blah.
OK. So, you executed a command
to get most of the URL--
or sorry, most of the HTML tags.
And whoa, we're in a really
weird place in these slides.
I'm sorry.
It's like this is
not making sense.
Let's move ahead.
Yeah. This is where
we want to be.
All right.
So, look for those carets to
denote the HTML tags or most
of them and then use
the regular expression
and then Python's replace
to get rid of what was
in between those tags.
So, it's simple and
also slightly broken.
And this is also not the most
robust way to remove the tags.
So, this is just
more for playing.
But if somebody were
working with lots of files,
they would want to
make modification
so that they could feed in
an entire directory of files
and not just one at a time.
Or if somebody had
used something
like Harriett mentioned
Beautiful Soup earlier.
The joy of Beautiful Soup is
that you can direct
your web scraping
to only grab what's
between certain tags.
And then you just skip
this whole mess altogether.
And we did that.
All right.
So, what did Sam do?
So when Sam was doing
his data preparation,
so remember when we last left
Sam, he had first generated
that very large list and then he
had started to lead down within
that list to hone
in on the volumes
that he really wanted
for his analysis.
And then he went a step further
to restrict the materials
that he was looking
at even more.
So the first thing that he did
was he only kept the pages,
the data that he was looking at,
retained page level information
so he could see this was
page 1, this was page 2.
And he said, I only
want the pages
that included my search term, so
that creativ with the asterisk.
And he got rid of
everything else
because he decided he
was most interested
in studying the discourse around
words like creativity or creativ
and he didn't care if the word
occurred at the very beginning
of the text and then at the
end never again, he didn't care
of what was happening
at the end of the work.
He just wanted to know
what was happening right
around that word.
But then proximity,
using pages is one way
to model that proximity.
And then, he discarded all
tokens such so as pronouns
and conjunctions that he
didn't think carried meaning.
So, he was keeping
what he considered
to be the most meaningful terms.
All right.
So, how many of you have read
this piece "Against Cleaning"
by Katie Rawson and
Trevor Munoz?
It's really nice.
We're not going to have
you read the whole thing.
But I'd recommend that you
do if you're interested
in exploring more of the
things that they're talking
about in the passage that
we're going to look at.
So, the project that they're
describing just for a little bit
of context was working with data
from the "What's on the Menu?"
project. And they were
talking about curetting menus,
are you familiar with this?
So, it's a big crowd
sourcing project
from the New York Public Library
where they transcribe menus
from restaurants in New York.
And then dealing with this
massive trove of data,
they had to decide, is
chocolate cake the same thing
as chocolate torte for
the purposes of our data,
is molten chocolate cake the
same thing as chocolate torte.
And so, they were thinking
through this process
of preparing and cleaning
their data and what these sort
of choices that they
were making,
how it would impact
research, their own research
and other's research
on the corpus.
All right.
So, here's the paragraph.
It's also on page
14 of your handout.
I'll give you just a
second to read through it.
OK. So, you made it to 151.
We finally talk about
analyzing text data.
You made it.
You didn't know you're
getting into, did you?
All right.
So, we divide this topic up just
like we did the gathering
text data piece
into two separate sections.
So, we're going to talk about
off-the-shelf-tools first
and then we're going to talk
about more advanced
do-it-yourself approaches
to text analysis.
So in this first half
that we're talking
about off-the-shelf tools, we're
going to discuss the benefits
and drawbacks of
using a pre-built tool
for text analysis.
We're going to learn about a
web-based topic modeling tool
from the HTRC.
And then, we're going to talk
about an attempt that Sam had
to use an off-the-shelf tool
for his analysis and talk
about his outcomes there.
All right.
So, where we'll end up,
we'll have some word clouds
of some topics related to
public papers from the 1970s.
All right.
So, there are a handful of
pre-built text analysis tools
on the market, so to speak.
The benefit of these tools is
that for the most part,
they're easy to use.
So, they give the
impression of plug and play.
You put data in.
Your results come out.
And because they don't
require programming or coding,
they are good for teaching
and for getting people
up and running.
But you-- Once you start working
with scholars in this field
for a little while, you find
that people have a threshold
in which they say like this
doesn't do what I want it
to do anymore, just
give me the data.
That's something that we
hear a lot from researchers,
just give me the data.
So, the drawbacks of using these
pre-built off-the-shelf tools
are that there's less control.
And then because of the
way that they're built,
there are limited capabilities
because you're constricted
by the system as it exists.
That said, it can
be very powerful
for getting people just started
with text analysis for teaching,
for quick examples where
you don't really need
to do a deep dive.
So, some examples here
are Voyant and Lexus
and then also the
HTRC algorithms.
So, we're going to be using
the topic modeling algorithm.
All right.
So then in contrast to
the off-the-shelf tools,
there are these do-it-yourself
tools.
So, these are an alternative
to these pre-built tools,
and they generally involve
some kind of programming.
So, you're going to have
to know how to code,
how to install things from
the command line usually.
You're going to have to have
sort of a deeper knowledge
of the files that you're
working with, file types,
and then also how to install
and get these programs going.
But the benefits are that you
are running them on your own.
So, it's more flexibility
for the researcher.
Generally, they allow for more
parameterization and control
over the research process.
But again, they require
that technical knowledge
that not everyone has and quite
honestly not everyone is willing
to pick up or wants to
pick up, and that's OK too.
But we're going to
return to these later.
Yeah?
[ Inaudible ]
Yes. Yeah.
So, you want to encourage
people to think critically
about the tool that they're
using, report which tool
that they use so that others
understand how they came
to their conclusions.
All right.
So when you go about the process
of picking a pre-built tool
or recommending a pre-built
tool, it really depends
on the goal of the
researcher which is sort
of a flippant thing to say here,
like well it depends, right?
But it really does.
So, the tools have different
strengths and weaknesses.
So if you want to do a quick
analysis, get a visualization up
and running really quickly.
Voyant and Lexus are fantastic.
They're easy to use.
You can run and-- You can
install and run Voyant locally,
but there is a web-based version
and Lexus is also web-based.
If you have a researcher who
wants to do concordances,
then they probably want to be
using a tool called AntConc
which I don't have
much experience with,
but my colleagues tell
me it's easy to use.
Voyant also has a nice
concordance function.
And then if someone
is interested
in doing machine learning,
there is a pre-built tool called
a WEKA, the WEKA workbench,
and that's another
one that you install.
You run it locally,
but it has an interface
that the researcher walks
themselves through in order
to carry out the
machine learning process.
So, they don't have to
program a tool themselves.
I hear typing.
So, I'm just going to pause.
All right.
Are we good?
OK. All right.
So, the tools that we're--
off-the-shelf tools
that we're looking
at in particular today are--
we're going to look at a topic
modeling tool that's part
of the suite of algorithms
provided
by the HathiTrust
Research Center.
So, the HTRC algorithms are plug
and play text analysis tools.
They're built into that
HTRC analytics interface,
and that means that
they're mostly as is.
So, you can do some
parameterization.
You have some choices
about how to run your job
when you do your analysis.
But you're limited in
what you're allowed to set
as a parameter and what is built
into the tool to ask the user.
And they're built specifically
to analyze HTRC worksets.
So the data that you moved
over earlier, that's the kind
of things that you can analyze.
In there, you can't
bring in outside data.
Because remember,
we're just looking
at these manifests
of volume IDs.
So, they're good
when you want to work
with HT texts specifically.
All right.
Some are task-oriented.
Others are more analytic.
We're going to be using the
topic modeling algorithm
which is more of an
analytic type algorithm
that helps the researcher
to get a feel
for the content of
their data set.
All right.
How many of you are familiar
with this idea of
a bag-of-words?
All right.
So, we're going to be
talking about topic modeling
in this algorithm, and
topic modeling is a kind
of text analysis process
that uses a bag-of-words
set of paradigm.
And when you're working
in this bag-of-words idea,
approach to text analysis, you
stop caring about the word order
and how it appeared on the page
and you just care
that it was there.
So, there are some algorithmic
processes that just want
to know what was in the text.
So, I sometimes imagine
this like I pick up the page
and I shake it off and
the words come down.
And now I have my bag
and I shake up my bag
and the order is lost.
So that means that
you're discarding things
like grammar as well.
So you're missing some of that
information but for the purposes
of these algorithms, the way
that they have been
conceived off by the folks
who built them is that that
is OK, that doesn't matter.
So here we see the
Gettysburg Address again
but we see the words
all jumbled up.
So this is our bag.
We have our bag of words
at the bottom, all right.
So we are talking
about topic modeling.
So here we see some
of our key terms
in the context of
topic modeling.
So when you go about
topic modeling,
when you use a topic modeling
algorithm, this is what happens.
You chunk the text, you
hack it up into documents,
and the documents
are just chunks.
They're pieces of text and those
documents are bags of words.
So the word order doesn't matter
within these chunks
of documents.
Generally, you remove stop
words or you remove some words.
So the tool we're using
today remove stop words.
Some topic modeling experts
are moving towards removing the
infrequently used terms
instead of the stop words.
But the one that we're going
to use today is the stop words
and that's sort of traditionally
how it's been done.
And then each word in
the document is compared
and it's sort of like the
computer picks up a word
and it goes, huh,
topic, what other bags,
what other documents
does this word appear in
and what other words
are around it.
Check, check, check,
check, check, OK.
Pick up another word, OK.
You know here is chunk, which
other bags is it in, OK.
And then it starts to
build a model, that's a--
it's a guess, it's
probabilistic to say I think
that if I find the word
Washington in this text,
it is likely to be in the
context of these other words.
And that is suggesting that
there's some kind of meaning
in the way that we choose to
talk about certain topics.
So if I'm talking about chicken
noodle soup, you're likely
to find words like bowl and
spoon and chicken and winter
and you're unlikely to find
things like sand, right?
So there-- it just follow some
sort of logical progression.
So the topic is just
a prediction
of word co-occurrence.
But don't think about
it as co-occurrence
as like the words
appeared side by side.
It's co-occurring in the same
bag, they're together in the bag
so they are conceptually
likely about the same thing.
All right, so here are some
tips for topic modeling.
A treat topic modeling is
one step in the analysis.
You don't just like throw
it in, beep boop boop
and then you get something
out and you're like, oh,
my text is about
whatever these topics say.
Again, input, just like
we talked about before,
it affects your output.
So you can start to [inaudible]
your analysis in certain ways,
such that maybe your
topics start to look
like what you expected by
getting rid of lots and lots
of words in your stop
word list and say
by doing topic modeling
over one novel, OK.
Well, I can read a novel, right.
I can tell you what
topics are in it.
The strength of topic
modeling generally has to do
with like lots of text, right?
So it tends to work better when
you're looking at more text.
You want to be somewhat
familiar with your input data
because there are some human
interpretation that happens
with your results, so you
need to be able to say like,
oh, no that's not good.
What made this result not good?
Is it my input data, is it
the way I set the parameters,
what do I need to do in order
to get results that are good?
And then you also need
to understand the tool
that you're using.
Depending on the tool, you'll
have different outcomes.
And so, you need to
know what's happening.
Just like Rick was saying,
if you want to go back
and defend your work, you need
to know actually what happened
with the tool that
you were using.
And if you can't speak
to what was happening
with the tool then you have less
firm ground to stand on in terms
of defending your results.
All right, so this
is the description
of the HTRC's topic
modeling algorithm.
The slide is probably a little
bit too small for you to see
but that's OK because you
all are going to read it.
So in-- well, actually,
let's see how we're
doing in terms of time.
No, you're not going to read
because it's going
to take too long, OK.
All right.
So what the HTRC topic
modeling algorithm does is
that it loads each page.
So in HathiTrust every
page is a separate file,
that's just an artifact
of the system.
So this algorithm treats
every page as a document
for the purposes of
the topic modeling.
It removes the first
and the last line.
So, it's doing some
preprocessing.
It joins hyphenated words that
occur at the end of the line.
It removes all tokens
that don't consist
of alphanumeric characters
and we're going
to see how there are some things
that squeak through anyway.
I remove stop words based on a
filter that is set by the tool.
So it's, again, a know
your tool sort of thing.
And then it uses MALLET.
How many of you have
heard of MALLET?
Great. So MALLET is a
pretty commonly used topic
modeling tool.
It uses MALLET on the back-end
to build out these topics.
All right.
So we're back with our
sample reference question.
And we are going to run
this algorithm all together
on the same work set so that
we all have the same results
to view together, because we're
going to go through the process
of thinking about the results.
All right.
So, bring out the
HTRC analytic site.
Make sure that you're
still logged in.
I might have booted you
because you've been inactive.
Yeah, sign in.
OK.
That should work.
That's how long every password
at Indiana University has to be.
So, I've-- We're going
to use just this one.
Yeah, I always tell people
[inaudible] it makes you feel a
little better for
having to do it.
All right.
So then once you're on
analytics.hathitrust.org,
you're signed in, you're
going to click algorithms
and you're going to see that
there are suite of tools here.
You're taking this
workshop at a--
not in opportune time but sort
of a weird moment because we're
in the process of
refreshing these.
So if you logged
back in next week,
the topic modeling algorithm
will be slightly different.
It will be slightly more robust.
Individualization
will be cooler.
So-- But this is just
a good time for us
to practice what it's
like to read the results
of a topic modeling algorithm.
All right.
So we have our description
here again
about what's happening
and you-- Let's see.
We are on page 16
of the handout.
So this is actually
not hard to do
and so I'm just going
to let you do it.
So follow the directions.
Run the topic modeling
algorithm.
The key thing here before you
get too far is that you want
to make sure you're
including public work sets
and then you want to make
sure that you're getting
to the same one that
we're all using.
So type in EF and then
hit the down arrow.
Yeah, you won't see all these.
These are mine.
Until you get-- These
are private.
So, it'll work for you.
Type EF and then hit
the down arrow once
and you'll find poli
underscore science
underscore ddrf@eleanordickson.
They're alphabetical
after the @ by username.
So--
We'll all get the same results
if we use the same parameters
because of the way the
results are being cached.
So, check steps 5 and 6 to
do the parameterization.
: So I'll mention two right now
that your jobs are going to go
through like look
at the split that's
because we're all doing the
same thing at the same time.
That's a job that's
was already run,
the exact the same parameters.
So if you're teaching
a workshop and you want
to make the time go faster,
run the job and advance
that you expect the
students to do.
The way that this is working
is that the job is being sent
to the computers at Indiana
University and then you get put
in a line with other jobs
on their compute cluster.
And so, if you have a really
big job, you might have to wait
in line longer, which isn't
how we're used to thinking
about computers very often right
now like, OK, I want results
but sometimes there-- it will be
sitting in that queuing and then
on the running if it's
really big for a while.
If it takes a really long
time, some things gone wrong
and you should cancel and
try again or contact someone.
But you can sometimes
have to wait a few minutes
to get results back, especially
if it's an intensive process.
All right, so here
are my results here.
It looks like most of
you have gotten them.
So we see the word clouds here.
We see this XML file.
This is part of what I was
saying would get more robust.
The result files are much
nicer and the update.
But you see the way that it's
weighted in the word cloud.
Then you can also look at the--
the words that appear
in each topic.
But I'm going to move
back to the slides
because it's actually
a little bigger there
and it will be easier
for us to look at.
All right.
So these are some of the
topics that were generated.
I guess these are all the topics
that were generated
when we run it.
The other thing to know
about topic modeling
because it's probabilistic,
means that outside
of this HTRC context where
the results are cached,
if you run a topic model
and then run it again
and then run it again,
you're going
to get a different results every
time because it's just a guess.
And so that's something
to expect to have happened
if you start getting
into topic modeling.
All right.
So look-- So you'll see that
they're just numbered zero
through four, so we
have five topics.
And they're not named, right?
The computer is not like,
oh yeah, this is, you know,
public parks or whatever.
So, what would you
name these topics?
Can you think of any
that seem like, OK,
I have an idea what
this topic is?
>> Well, number three
looks like foreign affairs.
>> Eleanor Dickson: OK.
Yeah foreign affairs.
Anything else?
>> Number one looks
like communications.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yup.
I definitely see
that, communication.
Anything else?
>> My favorite one is relating
to this propaganda flux.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah, yeah.
I like that one too,
propaganda flux, yeah.
Anything else?
>> Four. It's like economy
or resource infrastructure.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
So you know I didn't do which
I missed the key piece here,
which is what were the text
that we even looked at, right?
So, know your input date and
know your results, right?
So these are-- Remember
before we were looking
at those public papers when
we were doing the searching,
these are all of
the public papers
from presidents in the 1970s.
So these are topics
from the 1970s,
speeches across a couple
different presidents.
Any other thoughts here?
You'll see that we're getting
some weird tokens, right.
>> That was weird.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
We're seeing some artifacts
there, something is not--
something is a little funky
with the tokenization.
So that's a know your
tool sort of thing, right?
Yeah.
>> If you're thinking
about it in a context
of a time it's talking
about, you know, question
or it's trying to formulate
the topics before them.
So if it looks disconnected
but if you think about it
as to what might be going
on, you know, there's oil,
there's management
question, American,
good, is this trying to--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
>> -- create an order
where there's chaos.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
Go ahead.
>> A topic one looks to me
somehow like community building
or a consensus building.
A lot of words in there
are like the things
that someone would use
it and now you told
that these are speeches.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
>> So the kind of things that a
president might tell American--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes, yeah.
>> -- while working together
here in our government back
on track or that kind of sort
of that seems to be, what,
the purpose of it, bringing
the country together.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
Yeah. Do you feel like looking
at these you get a general idea
of what kinds of things
they might have been talking
about during that time period?
So someone might--
the topic by the way.
[ Inaudible ]
So it might be that for you,
you feel like we didn't
have enough data that went
in to get interesting
discernible topics
from one another?
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. You got a feel, OK,
they're talking about energy
and oil and these are the
kinds of words they're using
in the context of that topic.
Anything else?
Any other questions
about topic modeling?
I know it's sort of as-- can
feel like a strange concept.
Yeah.
>> Well I know-- I've
attended some other workshops,
I haven't done it myself
but approximately how
many pages was this?
>> Eleanor Dickson: Let's see.
So it was 19-- Somewhere
around 19 volumes, 16 to 19.
So, it's something like 2,000
or 3,000 pages probably.
>> OK. So that's a
huge number of chance
and a small number of topics.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
>> And so-- And this
looking at--
so it's looking across each
of those thousands of pages
and then trying to
find things that things
that are [inaudible] across--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yup.
>> -- all the stuff I think.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yup,
that's a great point.
So if we had run this
with more topics,
our results might have
felt more granular
or they would have
been different.
>> Like [inaudible]
might be able
to see more different prompts
or different kinds of concerns
like oil might broken
out from inflation.
>> Eleanor Dickson:
Yeah, absolutely.
That's a great point.
Yup, because we have quite a bit
of text and just a few topics.
>> And so that would be the
thing you might consider
adjusting to see
what [inaudible].
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes.
Yeah. This is the kind
of thing where you--
I understand your point.
You might go, OK, these
all seem really similar.
What happens if I bump
it up to 10 or 20?
Yeah. And then the new
algorithm that's coming out,
you can train a whole
bunch, 20, 40, 60,
80 and so you can get a feel
for what that looks like.
>> But you won't be able to
chunk larger than [inaudible]?
>> Eleanor Dickson:
I-- it's three--
I think it treats
every volume as--
I forget how it does
the chunking actually.
I shouldn't say.
Yeah.
>> [Inaudible] using the page.
>> Eleanor Dickson:
In here it's a page.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Any other thoughts?
Yeah?
>> So once you've got to the
topic modeling, if you wanted
to go back then to
find out which pages,
what is the impression of
those-- of your topics?
How do you get back
to [inaudible]?
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
That's a great question.
So that's to know
your tool thing.
With this tool we're not seeing
what volume these topics were
most prevalent in.
Some other topic modeling
tools allow you to say, oh, OK,
this is coming mostly
from this volume
or I can see the way
the volumes relate
to one another with the page.
And I know Harry has worked
on projects, topic modeling
where as a group because
she uses this nice example.
They did topic modeling and
then they divided it up.
You can correct me if I'm wrong.
But they would go back
to the original text
and think critically
about the topics
and then the pages they were
looking at in order to try
to hone in on what they thought
were the most relevant topics
and things like that.
Is that right?
OK. Yeah. So that
sort of going back
and forth is definitely a one--
that's why we talk about
topic modeling as one step
in the research process because
oftentimes researchers are going
back and forth.
Yeah. Did I answer the question?
>> So there are-- to a
lot of ways to do it.
>> Eleanor Dickson:
So with this tool, no.
That's a know-- Yeah.
That's a know your tool thing.
>> You have to have
a different tool.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
Yeah. So may-- so in this
case it's sort of like, OK,
I have a feel of the
contour of my data.
Maybe for the preliminary
researcher, that's enough
and we're going to see
how somebody used this
for preliminary research
or for our student, right?
But if you feel like
this is enough
for whatever they're
doing their coursework.
But for a published paper, if
you really wanted to go deep,
you might want to run
a more robust tool.
Yeah. Go ahead.
>> So, I mean, this is quite
interesting because it says
like nuclear definitely being
tied here at the military,
whereas the oil is
tied into like labors.
That's interesting.
But my question is like,
how confident can I be
that this is-- right, where
is the data behind that
or the numbers behind
like be confident
of the validity of
this distinction?
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
That's a good question.
Yeah.
>> Is the online data
or anything there?
I've got more background
in social science research.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes.
So, in this case you
could go back and look
at the public domain
volumes and--
because we were looking at
these presidential speeches,
and then you could get a feel
too for what you're seeing.
Oftentimes the results
of the topic modeling
algorithm will give you the
probability rankings.
But it's-- that's sort
of how you're building
your certainties.
It's also sort of like know what
you're putting in to get a feel
for what you're getting
out make sense.
Yeah. Go ahead.
>> So it's only a
different take on this.
Given the way this
is set up, this--
you've seen the volumes going
by [inaudible] where it seemed
to be more important because of
the format, the genre to do this
by paragraph, where you're going
by significant theme
in each paragraph.
>> Eleanor Dickson:
Or by speech, right?
So there are different ways
that a researcher might.
They might say, page
doesn't make sense for me.
Maybe I wanted it
to be a speech.
But do you think
that that would--
>> Oh, I-- It was a
couple of years ago
that I took the workshop,
so it's possible things have
evolved since then but--
and I can actually
[inaudible] for example.
A lot of people are arguing if--
that your chunks have
to be exactly the
same number of word--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Oh, yes.
Yeah.
>> -- and then--
>> Eleanor Dickson:
That's a good point.
Yeah.
>> -- you have to be
build there [inaudible]--
>> Eleanor Dickson: No.
You're right about that.
>> -- on the organization of the
actual content because you're--
of the [inaudible] of the
conscious organization
because what you're
trying to get
at is the unconscious
or assumptions--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yup.
>> -- that are embedded
in the text.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
No. That's a great point.
Yeah.
>> And so-- I mean if
you really want to get
into this [inaudible], there's
a ton of high level stuff--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
>> -- [inaudible]
and sometimes--
I'm not going to pronounce
it properly, I'm going to--
there's like a three name kind--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Oh,
latent Dirichlet allocation.
Yeah.
>> So you can read about
what the algorithms are.
OK. And the [inaudible]
interested and there's a lot
of great stuff out there that's
kind of complicating [inaudible]
that you may have
the benefit for it.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
And topic modeling I
think it was something
that people are really
excited about for a while
and then it had started to
wane in popularity with--
amongst certain researchers.
But it's, I think, really great
for conversation and workshop.
Yeah. OK. Yeah?
>> Just briefly.
This tool only work
with data [inaudible].
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes.
Yup. Yeah, these official
ones that are like that.
Yeah.
>> But like going on
you can put your--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
>> -- own [inaudible].
Yeah.
>> So [inaudible] that
box that can do this.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
Yes. Yeah.
Well, Voyant doesn't do
topic modeling but, yeah.
>> All right.
OK. Yeah. But some of them.
Sorry. Yeah.
>> Eleanor Dickson: All right.
So we did this.
All right.
So let's talk about
Sam really quickly.
So we've been tracking Sam on
the more successful track he was
on in his research project.
Remember at the very beginning
we talked about sort of the fits
and starts of doing
this kind of research.
So before Sam started building
out his true Creativity Corpus,
he built a corpus of text
from the public domain--
from 1950 on that included the
word creativity in HathiTrust.
And then he used the HTRC
topic modeling algorithm
to get a feel for
what was there.
And these are some of
the topics that he got.
They might be pretty
small for you.
Hopefully you can see them OK.
Thanks. Well, actually,
let me do this.
So I'm just going to zoom in.
I don't know.
I can do that.
All right.
Does that help you
see it all though?
OK. Well, I might
have just ruined it.
No.
Yeah. This is what
I get for closing
with the mouse, isn't it?
OK. Well, I'm not going to
try to make it bigger for you.
That was a failure.
All right.
Here they are again.
OK. So these are some of
the topics that he got.
What do you think
about these topics?
So, he has things like system
planning, state, local, public,
programs, children time, school,
children education, science,
life, human, man, world, nature,
body, forms, here's order, form.
What do you think
about these topics?
Yeah?
>> Can I have kind of
a procedural question?
Well, just putting them in
order, I've noticed for instance
when we did this test
that the first group
of the letters were smaller.
Does that mean that, I mean,
is there any rhyme or reason
to how they are presented
in this order?
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
So the color doesn't mean
much except that it seems
like there's some kind of
ranking that happens in terms
of like this big
one is dark blue.
But the size has to
do with the prevalence
of that word within the topic.
>> So, for instance on our
first result of what we did,
nothing was a standout.
And that means that all
of those words occurred
about the same time.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Within the
context of those other words.
Yeah. But sometimes
there's one that's like sort
of more salient terms, it's more
characteristic of the topic.
>> So is there a reason
why one comes back with one
and the next one is two
and the next one is three?
>> Eleanor Dickson: No.
I don't think that that order--
I don't think that
order has meaning.
>> So that's just random?
>> Eleanor : Yeah.
I'm pretty sure that that
is not a meaningful order.
>> I think it has to do
with the order in terms
of the words in the test.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
>> As knowledge go through.
>> Eleanor Dickson: But
I don't think it means
like this one is the most
important topic or something.
But I'm-- I would want to
check myself before I say
that with certainty.
Yeah. All right.
Any thoughts about
Sam's topics here?
Yeah? Go ahead.
>> So I think it's interesting
just the different facets
of creativity that
it's demonstrating.
Some of them I would have
expected [inaudible] like art
and colors and children,
but the [inaudible],
I have like state
and local like--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
>> -- many.
If we think about like
there's creativity in planning
that happens, would that
wouldn't have been right?
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
>> So, it was just kind
of surprising thing,
but I can see how it fits.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Can anyone
think of why you're seeing a lot
about state and local
government?
>> Yeah.
>> So, I was thinking
about that corpus
and then it's 1950
[inaudible] literature
which are mostly [inaudible].
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
Yeah. So--
>> That's an easy--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
So, if you're interested
in tracking how the term
creativity changes over time,
do you think that only
looking at public domain
after 1950 is the best way
to build your dissertation?
Probably not.
Yeah. So this goes back-- yeah?
>> [Inaudible] if you go back.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
>> You see man and man--
Uh-huh.
>> -- that's the one.
And if you were combining
[inaudible]
and man together it
would be twice as big.
And so, yeah, there's been
some kind of [inaudible] about,
you know, the benefit to
man if people but other--
on the right people
is the biggest word
in a very small topic
over there.
So the [inaudible] would
explore that more [inaudible].
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
Yeah. That's really interesting.
>> You could see
one in [inaudible].
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
Yeah. So this is an
example of being familiar
with your input text and then
also examining your results
to see if they make sense.
So you could see a less
discerning researcher getting
this out and writing a
chapter of their dissertation
with some thoughts about the way
that the term creativity has
changed to be really important
in governmental documents
or government speak.
But Sam thought, I don't know.
This isn't quite right.
So what he ended up doing was
taking a different approach.
So this is the sort
of start and the stop
of this kind of research.
So that's when he started using
those extracted features files.
So he was able to get a
data that was in copyright
and not just in the
public domain.
So he could make the argument
that he wanted to
make in his work.
All right.
So this again we just throw it.
So if you missed when I was
showing the slide earlier,
all of the examples of the
tools, this is a good time
to start scribbling
them down again.
So, again, these are some
other pre-built tools.
Which one you would want to
recommend depends on the goal
for analysis, something
like Voyant
and Lexos are good
web-based tools.
They make really pretty
nice clean visualizations.
Lexos has a text
cleaning function built-in
which I find quite nice.
AntConc for concordances,
the WEKA again
and then the HTRC
algorithms if you want
to us HT text specifically.
All right.
I want to see how
we're doing on time.
Anyway, we're not too far back.
OK. So can you think
about the kinds
of researchers you might
recommend these off the shelf
tools to?
And if you have done this
before this recommending,
what techniques have you used
for introducing them
to researchers?
Yeah? Yeah.
Go ahead.
>> I'm going to be talking
to some graduate students
with childhood studies
coming up and they're going
to be doing more
social science research.
And I'm thinking this is
something they might really be
interested in because
there would be a lot
of [inaudible] documents and
all that to check and see,
the children's bureaus
and their mother's bureau.
But if they could narrow
beyond just that document set,
maybe I can put that
together for them in advance.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
>> Then they could use that
as a way to practice looking
for terms or just using
that as a dataset.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
That's great.
>> I did have one question
because I was wondering
if there's any way, so
I've worked with someone
who is doing a lot of research
on comparing the number of miles
and roads in specific
countries and we've used Hathi
and it will come up with charts.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
The charts.
Yeah.
>> Is there any way to pull
out the data from charts?
>> Eleanor Dickson:
Not without going back
to the original document
and redoing the OCR process.
>> So, no?
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
It's really complicated.
Yeah. Yeah.
I wish it were easier.
Yeah. Any other questions
or thoughts?
Yeah?
>> Well, this again is
in researcher's first
say or for the purpose.
I guess what I'm
trying to say is some
of these tools are really
good way to convince people
that there might be a benefit
to exploring digital research
in either the humanities
and the social sciences
that haven't been
already doing it.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Right.
>> Because it is-- especially
we find ways these things would
seem relevant to them--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Right.
>> -- and [inaudible] an example
that teaches them a little bit
of something because there's
a lot of skepticism now
about why should we be investing
in this infrastructure.
This is just me speaking.
We're here at the library.
There's an infrastructure
of providing the content
to researchers and then there's
the additional infrastructure
of training our own staff
to understand what the
researcher is doing with it
and both of those
are requiring some--
>> Eleanor: Yeah.
>> -- the report.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> So, actually having
people see the results can be
very helpful.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
And a good way to say, OK,
here are some possibilities
and you don't have to learn
how to code right now.
That doesn't have
to be step one,
I need to become a programmer.
Yeah. Just what's possible.
>> Yeah. And just, you
know, it shows some of these
to not [inaudible] they do,
but they help people understand
the work that's being presented
to them.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yup.
Yeah.
>> So they can understand
the concepts too,
concepts [inaudible].
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
So they can evaluate
other's work better.
Yeah. Did you have a--
>> Yeah. I was just going to
[inaudible] off the shelf tools
or anything that's
an assignment.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
>> If they-- I mean at the
most they have a semester tour
about that.
Your average [inaudible] tough
time to learn how to code.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. That's great.
It's like what are you--
what's the skill you're
trying to teach them?
Is the skill the
interpreting the results?
Is the skill the using the tool
or is it learning
how to program?
And a sort of a weighing--
oftentimes you can
get bogged down.
Yeah. Any other thoughts?
Yeah?
[ Inaudible ]
Yes. Yeah.
Yeah. So there is-- we
are leaving into a break.
So I'm going to go
out of the slides.
And I'll show you where
you can find the list.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. So, the unfortunate
thing about the way--
So, it's really hard to
tokenize certain languages.
So, split it into
chunks because of the way
that the characters
are rendered.
Especially CJK characters,
the Chinese, Japanese
and Korean characters, the
tokenization is just bad
and the tools don't
work as well with them.
The topic modeling tool that
we have right works best
on English language text
and it does OK I think
with some non-English text.
But if it's non-Roman
characters,
then it gets really wonky.
But I will show you here
just the list of languages.
So you have an idea of
what some of those--
some of the breakdown is like.
You can see it's quite
a bit of English.
And then there's quite a bit
of German and French and sort
of tails off from there.
Yeah. OK. So we're going
to come back to talking
about Python a little bit more
thinking again at how you pick
up and reuse somebody else's
code that they've written.
And also we're going to talk
about installing
libraries for Python.
They mix it so that you can
do research more easily,
do work more easily.
So we're going to review
some text analysis strategies
for advanced researchers
to think about when
to make skill-appropriate
recommendations.
We'll explore text analysis
methods in more depth.
We'll use an HTRC dataset
to conduct exploratory
data analysis.
And then of course
we'll see what's handed.
All right.
So this is where
we're going to end up.
We're going to create a list of
the top adjectives in a volume
and then-- or a directory of
volumes, and then we're going
to look at the word count
by page in a volume.
All right.
So, what I want us to do
is look at these three--
No, if two, two broad areas,
key approaches to text analysis
and then you're going to do a
little activity in small groups.
All right.
So, sometimes when you're
thinking about text analysis,
you hear people talking about
natural language processing.
Is that a term that you
all are familiar with?
OK. So, natural language
processing is using computers
to understand the meaning,
relationships and semantics
within human-language text.
So some specific
methods are things
like named entity extraction.
So what are the names of the
people, places, organizations,
the dates that can be-- a
certain kind of entity extracted
that appear in a text.
Sentiment analysis is another
kind of an LP processing.
So, what does this text--
what is the mood or the
feeling of this text?
Is it positive, is it negative?
And then there's
also a stylometry.
So, what can we learn from
measuring features of style
in this text that tell
us something about work.
And then in this other
bucket, we can think
about machine learning
as another approach
to text analysis.
So machine learning is training
computers to recognize patterns.
So remember text analysis,
relevant patterns, right?
So two specific methods that
we mention are topic modeling
and naive Bayes classification.
So topic modeling is what
we just looked at obviously.
And topic modeling doesn't
take much human input.
It's unsupervised.
So you throw some
data at the computer,
you set some parameters
and you get something out
and then you think
about your results.
But that training piece, the
computer is doing it on its own
without much information
from you, guidance from you
about what to do
or how to do it.
I mean, it's just
running a process.
That's specified.
We can contrast that with
naive Bayes classification
which is supervised
machine learning.
So in supervised
machine learning,
the human tells the
computer some information.
It keys it up, it precedes
it with some information
and then it asked to learn based
on the information
that it was provided.
So that's supervised
machine learning.
And naive Bayes classification
is an example
of supervised machine learning.
So, a kind of research
question you might ask are
which of the categories
that I have named does
this text belong to?
So you could say, hey, computer,
here are some fiction written
by women in Britain
in the 1900s.
And here are some
fiction written by women
in the US in the 2000s.
Here is a blob of text,
a whole mass of text,
you go through them and tell
me if it was written by a woman
in 19th-- yeah, 1900s,
in 19th century Britain.
I'm just messing
with my examples now.
Or in the 2000s in the US,
that was our two groups, right?
So you tell me based on
what I told you was true
for this smaller subset what
is true about the larger group.
So that's naive Bayes
classification.
All right.
So you're going to look
back at those examples
that we read way
back this morning,
are those research examples
that you read through.
And in pairs or by
yourself if you want to,
but we prefer you work in
small groups if you don't mind.
Go through and identify
the broad area
and then the specific method.
And again these broad areas
are NLP and machine learning.
And then the specific methods
are named entity extraction,
sentiment analysis and
stylometry and topic modeling
and naive Bayes classification.
And if you need to
go back to look
at the research examples
again to remember,
there's a link here
that's up on the screen.
What's the broad area for the
Rowling and Galbraith example?
>> Stylometry, because I just
found it in Scientific American.
>> Eleanor Dickson: OK.
So that's our specific
method, that's great.
And what's the broad area?
>> Natural language processing.
>> Eleanor Dickson:
Natural language processing.
So to do NLP, we need the
words in order on the page
and we often leave in
for stylometry at least--
We don't take these [inaudible]
words out, they're kept in.
Because those tell us something
about the writing style
which can help us figure
out who wrote something.
All right, what about
significant themes
in 19th century literature?
What's the broad area?
>> Machine learning.
>> Eleanor Dickson:
Machine learning, good.
And a specific method?
[Inaudible] Great.
All right.
And then the emergence
of literary diction,
what's the broad area?
>> Machine learning.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Good.
And the specific method?
>> Naive Bayes.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah, naive
Bayes classification, yeah.
So they said here are some
fiction, here are some poetry,
here are some prose,
now you tell us
which category the
text belongs to.
And then they were able to
chart out this change over time.
All right.
So, throughout the
day we've come back
to a few different
ways of looking
at a text analysis workflow.
So, this is another
way that you can think
about how the research
process progresses just sort
of flipped in a new way.
So you can think about the
workflows going like this.
You have raw text and then
you do some preparation,
so you deduplicate, you get
rid of some of the pages,
you get your corpus ready to go.
You do the normalization,
the cleaning.
And then we translate
the text into features
and that's where we are now.
So remember we're
getting the text
into something that
can be counted.
It's all about counting.
So we need something
the computer can count.
So those are the features
and we're going to talk
about a dataset that's
all features and what
that means in a second.
And then you can plug that
in for algorithmic use.
So, within HTRC, we can think
about features as they relate
to a dataset that's called the
extracted features dataset.
And Harriet mentioned this
really briefly early on.
We were talking about
Sam like, oh hey,
Sam downloaded extracted
features.
So now we're circling
back around to that.
So the extracted features
dataset is a downloadable
dataset of 15.7 million
volumes from HathiTrust.
So including both the
public domain and the--
in copyright data and they
are meant for the researcher
who wants to work on their
own machine or outside
of our systems, who
is interested
in having a little bit of
the processing of the text
on their behalf, and I'll say
more about that in a second.
And who is also able and willing
to work with bags of words.
So you can't do NLP with these
because the word order
is not there anymore,
but you can do any analysis
that requires bag of words.
So this slide is out of date.
It should be 15.7.
And I forget what the billion
of page this is but it's a lot.
All right, so sometimes you
call EF, extracted features.
So these features are
selected data and metadata
from every page in every volume
within that 15.7 million
volume snapshot of the corpus.
And they're extracted
from the raw text
and the metadata
for those volumes.
And they're meant to
position the researcher
to begin their analysis.
So, a lot of text
analysis starts or proceeds
with this translation
into features.
And so, by providing the text
as features, HTRC is one,
poising the researcher to
begin their study and also two,
making it so that the release
of this massive dataset
is non-consumptive.
So the text is not recreatable.
So that's one solution
for providing access,
a derived dataset
in copyright text.
All right.
So, do you know what
the features look like?
So, there is-- They're in JSON
format which you saw earlier
when we used the bibliographic
API, what JSON looks like.
How many of you are
familiar with JSON?
Great. So if you can read
XML, you can read JSON.
JSON, the structure,
it's nested like XML is.
It's just less verbose.
There's no opening
and closing tags.
You just see the blue
text before the colon.
It's-- I think it's
nicer to read.
OK, so it's JSON format
and there is one
JSON file per volume
in that 15.7 million
volume snapshot.
And then within every
one of those JSON files,
there's a hierarchy
in a structure
and that's what we're
running through now.
So at the top of the file,
there are per volume features.
So, bibliographic
metadata about the volume.
And then there is information
like what language
is this volume
that the cataloger
said that it was.
Some identifiers, the title,
things like that, some dates.
And then nested under that,
for every page in the volume,
there is more metadata.
So there are per page features.
So there's the page sequence.
So this doesn't correspond to
the page number at the bottom
of the page but it
corresponds to the scan order.
So if they scanned all of
the, you know, opening pages
which they often do, then
it would start with 000001,
and that might be the cover,
it might be the inside
page, et cetera.
OK, so the sequence, and then
there's computationally-inferred
metadata.
So this isn't the
bibliographic metadata.
This is metadata that was
inferred in the process
of creating these
features files.
So there are things
like how many words,
lines and sentences
appeared on that page
and how many of them were empty.
So then you could say like, huh,
look, here are all of the places
in this file where the
page is mostly empty.
Maybe it has an image on
it, maybe it's the beginning
or the end of a chapter.
And you could start
to use these features
to understand the
contours of your data.
And then there's also
computationally-inferred meta--
language, sorry,
at the page level.
So the computer will say this
page is in English, this page is
in French which is more
nuances than you might get
from just a larger
catalog record.
OK. So then we are like moving
our way down the hierarchy.
And so then within each page
section, we break the page
up into three pieces,
header, body and footer.
So you can see the way that
we have this highlighted here
yellow across the
top for the header
and then the body
is outlined in red.
And then you'll see
some of these things
that might get picked up.
OK. So, for each of these
pieces, for each page
in the volume, the header,
body and footer, there is line,
empty line, and sentence count.
So you have it for the whole
page and then you have it
for the section, then you
have the counts of beginning
and end-line characters and
then you have token counts.
And what are tokens?
>> Words.
>> Words, OK.
So then we have words
and word counts.
And so, you'll see here that we
have things, OK, token count,
line count, empty line count.
We're moving down.
And then we have all of
the tokens that start.
And you'll see that they're
tagged with a part of speech.
This is so that the part of
speech information isn't lost
when the bag of words
is created.
So we're keeping some
of that meaning there.
And you'll see that they
are marked with that code,
that two-letter code which
is from the Penn Tree Bank.
Are any of you familiar
with the Penn Tree Bank?
OK. So, this is a standard
linguistics coding system
for languages, or I'm
sorry for parts of speech.
So JJ is adjective,
NNP is proper noun.
And so this provides
some additional context
about the information.
But look, we have all of
the words that appeared
on this page, just not the
order in which they appeared.
OK. So you could identify
the parts of the book,
you could do topic modeling,
you could classify the volume,
sort of like that example we saw
where they were saying
this is fiction,
this is nonfiction prose.
All right, any questions
about that?
We're sort of like [inaudible].
We're going to come
back to it in a second.
Yeah.
>> Can you just go back just--
You said that there
is one JSON file per--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Volume.
>> -- volume.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes.
>> OK.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
>> All right.
So, they take the--
all of the plain text
that constitutes a volume
and then they process it
and they spit out a JSON file
that corresponds to the volume.
And then within that JSON file,
that file is broken
up into the sections.
>> So you're-- with this
dataset you're working
with 15.7 million files?
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes.
But you don't have to
get all 15.7 million.
>> Sure.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> All right.
>> Eleanor Dickson: I
say that as a warning
because if you did
it would like, yeah,
you could be the-- Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Eleanor Dickson: OK.
>> So the number after the--
of each tag, is that
the difference?
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah, it's
the number of times it occurred
in that section of the page.
>> That have style [inaudible].
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah, yeah.
And we had a question earlier.
I can't remember who asked it.
I think that you
did in the front
about stripping away the
headers and the footers and what
if you didn't actually
want it gone?
So it was you, right?
So in this dataset, the idea is,
well, we prepped the researcher
so that if they want to
take it out, they can.
But if, for some reason,
you think that your data is
less likely to have a header
and a footer line and you want
to keep it in, or you think
that it's important for your
work for whatever reason,
we haven't taken it all away.
It's still there so you could
knit the pieces back together.
Yeah, go ahead.
>> So I'm still [inaudible]
to understand what's
in [inaudible].
So it's one JSON file--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
>> -- and it has information
about the whole book at the top.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes.
Yeah.
>> And then page by page.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
It says here's page one, here's
some information about it.
And page one, the
header has this,
the body has this,
the footer has this.
>> And all these words--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes.
>> -- are there?
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yup.
And here's page two and it
has a header, body, footer.
>> It doesn't have
the [inaudible] text.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah, it
has the words and the number
of times that they occurred,
part of speech tagged, yeah.
Any other questions?
OK. So we're going to sort of--
we're doing like a zigzag here.
So we're going to
talk a little bit more
about do-it-yourself
text analysis.
So some researchers will not
want to use off-the-shelf tools.
They are just not
going to want to do it.
They're great for
getting their feet wet
but they are just not
going to be satisfied
and they're going to want more.
And those are the
just give me the data
and let me do my
work kinds of people.
And we are going to talk about
what kinds of tools those kinds
of researchers use
for their analysis.
So that kind of researcher
wants more control
over the processes
of their analysis.
They want to know the intimate
details of what's happening
and they really want to
be able to parameterize
and set the specifications for
the work that they're doing.
And so this do-it-yourself
approach is often a
mix-and-match sort of
combination of various tools
like programming languages
you can think of as a tool
that a researcher is
going to put together
and they might use one tool
at one point in the research
and another tool
at another time.
All right, so this toolkit
is researcher-dependent.
There are wars fought
over Python versus R
and people have strong
feelings about it.
And so it's really-- it's about
what the researcher wants.
There's no right
tool necessarily,
it's really researcher-driven.
And generally, to be able
to do this kind of work,
you need some understanding
of statistics
because remember
it's all counting.
So you need to understand
what your results are.
And so this leads me to the
point that it often draws
on expert collaborators.
So we sometimes see
in digital humanities
and text analysis research teams
where you have people pairing
up in collaborations
or partnerships
where someone is crunching
data or analyzing data
in combination with
somebody else.
And the toolkit consists
of command line tools
and programming languages.
All right, so what
are those tools?
So some general command-line
tools that are commonly used--
and by command-line tool,
I mean, you install it
on your computer and you
run it from the command-line
but you're not doing
computer programming.
So MALLET is one tool
we talked about earlier.
That's a command-line tool.
And there are set sort of
instructions that you follow
that are MALLET and you run
it from the command-line
so you say like, MALLET
do this, MALLET do that
and you feed data in,
you set parameters
and you get an output.
And MALLET is good
for topic modeling
and it can also do some
kinds of classification.
Some researchers used this--
they use Stanford
suite of NLP tools
for natural language processing.
MALLET and Stanford's NLP are
both Java-based and I think both
of them have a graphical-user
interface that you could use
if you didn't want to use
it on the command-line.
But oftentimes these sorts
of researchers are using
them on the command-line.
OK, and then there
are code libraries.
So someone asked earlier
about code libraries.
So this is the time when
we're talking about that.
All right, so part
of programming is
re-using code, all right.
So no one is starting from
zero when they're programming.
You've got a computer, it
has an operating system
like something has been done
for you generally before
you get started, right?
So just think about the library
as a crutch, a support tool, a--
an implement that allows
you to perform certain tasks
that somebody else wrote and
described and you just sort
of like slide it in
to your work, OK?
So often you share
these like chunks
of existing code as a library.
So you'll say, oh, I'm
going to use this library.
You install it via a package.
And I mentioned this
because we're going
to use a package manager.
We're installing the
library via package.
And then the packages are
collections of bits of code
that are made up into modules.
And this is all-- I will
show you how this looks
like in a second.
And then these modules
facilitate the
programming tasks.
So I'm a visual person.
You can think about
it a little bit
like a screwdriver kit, right?
So here is my library
which is the big kit
and then I have a head
for the screw driver
that does different tasks.
Here is my one that's
going to, oh god, open,
flat-head screw, right?
So, my flat-head
screwdriver, right?
OK, well that's like
tokenizing the text, right?
So they correspond to a task.
So they all-- they
have-- each play a part.
All right, so I like this tweet.
We don't have the notes up
here so I'm unfortunately going
to remember this person's
like non-Twitter name.
But they said, "Me on Python,
spend two hours working at how
to do X, discover a library
design to do X better.
Spend three hours
wading into the library.
Repeat." And this is
sort of a common workflow
for the beginner
programmer where you think,
I'm going to do this
thing and I'm going
to make it all by myself.
And then you're like, oh,
somebody already did that,
and there's a tool, there's a
library I can use and it's like,
oh, crap, I got to figure
out how to use the library.
So this is sort of
a common cycle.
OK. So to install a
package for Python,
you use a package manager.
And we're going to use one
today that's called pip
and that comes preinstall-- like
it's preinstalled with Python.
So, if you're running
Python on your computer
or you installed Python,
it's going to include pip,
so you could pip install things.
And the general syntax
to pip install,
use a pip install, the thing.
And then pip goes out and
gets the thing for you
from wherever it lives say
on Github or another website.
There are other installers
that people use,
other package managers
like Homebrew.
Another one is Conda.
So if you are running
a machine right now
where you haven't done a lot of
Python programming but you want
to get started, I would
recommend downloading
and installing Anaconda.
And Anaconda, their package
manager is called Conda.
But Anaconda is robust.
It includes lots of libraries so
you don't have to install them.
OK. All right, so if you want
to use a library's module
and a script, remember
the modules are
like the heads of
the screwdriver.
You have to import-- Do
these import statements
at the beginning.
So when you just start
programming or wanting
to reuse somebody
else's code, open it up
and see what they
imported at the beginning.
Because if you just like
download somebody's file and try
to run it using your Python run
the script and then you're going
to get an error like,
what's Pandas?
I don't know, computer
doesn't know, right?
So look at the import
statements at the beginning
and see what libraries
they're using
because you better have those
installed on your computer
so that you can reuse them.
So that's where you
go to look to see, OK,
these are the dependencies
that I need to have installed
and ready to go in order
to reuse the script.
So this will get declared at the
top and then they get reused.
So, I'm going to step away
from the mic, which is not good
for the recording, but we
see import Pandas as pd.
And then look, if
we look down here,
we see pd is being
referenced again.
That's because we're
using a little bit
of the Pandas to the spit.
Does that make sense?
So you bring it in and then
you write it into your code
and the Pandas help do
the process for you.
OK. So, some common Python
text analysis libraries.
SciKit learn is a really popular
one for machine learning.
Pandas is a common one
for doing data science.
We're going to-- The tool--
The library we're going to use
relies partially on Pandas.
NLTK, if you're like,
well, I would really
like to learn Python in the
context of text analysis,
I recommend starting with NLTK
because they have the most
beautiful book that's online
and they have activities and
you can sort of teach yourself
in the context of NLTK.
All right, so can you use
your imaginations and think
about what nltk dot words
underscore tokenize would do
for you as part of
the NLTK library?
Yeah.
>> It would [inaudible]
words in a day.
>> Eleanor Dickson:
Yeah, we would--
well, it would break
our text into tokens.
So we're creating the tokens.
Remember I said no
and is like doing--
They're not like
human doing something.
Here, we've made tokens now.
We're getting ready for
the text to be processed.
OK. All right, so the
library we're going
to use today is the Feature
Reader Python library,
and it was developed
by some of the folks
who are affiliated with HTRC.
And it's meant to interact with
the extractive feature file,
so it makes processing and
analyzing those files easier.
So it's meant to parse the JSON.
Sometimes people
ask where it lives.
I love this question.
It lives on Github
and we're going
to go get it from
Github with pip.
And if you want to use it, you
have to have Pandas installed.
And lucky for us Pandas
is installed already
in Python anywhere, so we
don't have to do any of that.
All right.
So, oh no, let's go back to
our sample research question.
And I'll show you this because
I think it can be helpful.
So we are going to pull out--
first we're going to
install the Feature Reader
and then we're going to pull out
the top adjectives in our file
and we're going to compare
two directories of files.
One directory of extracted
features files relates
to that work set that
you used earlier,
so it's all of the same
volumes but they're rendered
in extracted features.
And then we're going to look
at the presidential
papers from the 1930s.
So we're just going to see
how we can compare the two.
Is there anything else here?
No. OK. So let's do
our pip installation.
All right, so we need to--
make sure I'm not going
too far off script.
OK, so we want to pip install
the HTRC Feature Reader.
We're on page 19 of
the handout, step 3.
So when you're pip
installing in Python anywhere,
you'll see that we have to
use this dash, dash user tag
and that dash, dash user tells
Python anywhere that you want
to install it in
your user account.
Otherwise the pip
install doesn't work.
You don't always
have to do that.
This is sort of a
Python anywhere thing.
OK. Or an option
in Python anywhere.
OK, so you do pip
install dash, dash user
and then you do HTRC
Feature Reader.
And then through the magic
of the package installer,
the package handler, this is
why I'm using one that's nice.
It goes out, it finds the code
on Github and then it stalls.
I have it already installed
so it says it's satisfied.
It doesn't have to do anything.
So did you all get it installed?
It's thinking?
[ Inaudible Discussion ]
OK.
>> So the final in
Github is the [inaudible]
for anyone to [inaudible].
It's not a user [inaudible]?
>> Eleanor Dickson: So yeah.
So let's-- I'll show you
what it looks like here.
[Inaudible] So yeah, to open
and then if you want it,
there's documentation
here and the date--
the actual library is in--
which one would it be in?
Scripts, I think.
I don't know.
Actually I'm not going
to say which one it's in
but there's documentation here.
It comes and it gets
it from this.
And the library is--
[ Inaudible ]
I'm trying to figure out which
is a good link that I want.
Yeah, OK. So the
library is things
like defining functions for you.
So it's like bits-- like
little bits of Python code
that are prewritten and
yeah-- And so this--
the files where this
lives on Github.
And then the package manager
goes and gets it for you.
[Inaudible] Yes, yeah.
[Inaudible] Yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it's just like a
slightly different interaction
than if you were to-- I'm
really bad at Github, like fork
or download something
from Github.
It's just the package manager
handles the installation for you
and it like tries to do nice
things like manage the versions
of software that you're using.
Yeah. All right.
How's it going?
Got it?
>> Yes.
>> Eleanor Dickson: All
right, easy enough, right?
OK, so now we're going to do--
We're going to look
at the top adjectives.
So we're on step 5.
So enter in your command to
look at the top adjectives.
So remember we start with
Python, top adjectives,
that's the name of the
script we're running, dot py.
And then we have to give
it a directory name,
because the directory name
is expected as an argument
for the script to run.
So you'll see we have a
variable called decade
and it's asking for
one argument.
And so that argument
is our directory.
Assumes extracted features are
stored in directories labeled
by decade and requires that
the directory name be supplied
in running the script.
So that's-- We have
that commented here.
And then you'll see at the top
of the script we're importing.
So we're importing
feature reader
from the HTRC Feature Reader.
We're importing this module--
yeah, module called glob,
which is my favorite,
because you get to write.
Wait for it.
Oh man, I ruined the joke.
Where did it go?
Yeah, oh here we go.
Yeah, you got it right.
Glob, glob, which is the best
part of this thing, right?
And that's basically
just setting
up your directory path for you.
And then, what else
do we have here?
We have Pandas, remember
that's installed as pd.
And then sys again,
sys is what's doing this whole
thing about the argument.
All right, so then if we run it,
it's going to take a little
while because it's going
through all of those files
that are pretty structured,
the data is pretty
structured and it's pulling
out every time it
sees the JJ code.
Every time it's saying the
adjectives or every time I find
in the JSON, one of the terms
that's called JJ, tagged as JJ,
and then it's appending
them to a list and counting.
So we're going to get overall of
those volumes the total number
of times they occurred.
Oh, and we're done.
>> The directories,
are those pre--
would you if you found that
it-- the featured [inaudible].
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
>> You would have to create
your own reference for--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so you could look at--
I mean in this case you wouldn't
have to do it by decade.
In this example we are but
you could do it by author,
whatever you wanted, and
you could feed in a set.
Yeah. All right, so once
you get your 1970s list,
do it again with the 1930s
directory and then talk
to your neighbor
about what you see.
If you are like, this is boring,
I need something else to do
or you finished discussing
with your neighbor earlier,
see if you can edit
the script to look
for a different part of speech.
And there are some
hints at the bottom
of page 19, about
how to do that.
[ Inaudible ]
They're the extracted
features files
for the presidential papers
to that corresponding decade.
[ Inaudible ]
So the one nice thing
about the feature reader is
that you don't actually
have to unzip the files.
But if you wanted to--
just like we used unzip
with our activities files
for the bz2 you use bunzip2
and then you could look at
the file if you wanted to.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes, yeah, the presidential
papers in that decade.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Or there's fewer volumes,
right, I think the-- yeah.
But that's the sort of
thing you would want
to not use raw counts
for probably, right?
>> Sure.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
Do some percentage.
And so this is what you're
seeing in your console
where it sort of looks
like a spreadsheet.
That's a Pandas data frame.
Just in case for the curious.
Yeah. Go ahead.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, it is other.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, it is actually
the word other.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. So there's no
normalization that happens here,
and that's interesting.
That's the sort of thing where
you'd want to look at that
and go, huh, let me open up
these files or let me search
through them, use grep
or something and pull
out the capital,
right, and try to figure
out why that's the case.
And it could be a weird
thing where they're thinking
like you're saying, oh, you
know, president so and so,
maybe they think it's describing
that so and so, right,
some sort of tokenization
error probably.
Yeah, go ahead.
>> On 1970s, the one, two,
three, four, fifth one down,
and then again in-- now,
just the 1970, it lists--
it's just like a hyphen or a--
>> It is [inaudible].
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah,
so that's another
tokenization error, right?
So, this is the sort of
thing where you're playing
around with your data
and you'd want to think
like what is this
underscore, right?
And that's the importance of
the human here to go, well,
I'm not going to shape an
academic argument that says
like the underscore
was quite important
to president speak--
right, you know.
So that's some like
error here and the way
that the text is tokenized.
>> Is there a change
since you did it?
It's not getting
different results.
>> Eleanor Dickson: So somebody
asked abut that recently
and I don't think that
we had rerun them,
but maybe the version
that we are using
on the instructor's guide, like
maybe it's slightly different.
It shouldn't be different but
we have that earlier this week.
So it could be that there
are slightly different files.
[ Inaudible ]
Interesting.
[Inaudible] Yeah, it could
be in the process of some
of our going back and forth
between versions that we're--
I'm using an older
version of files or one say
that has one fewer extracted
features file, right,
which would account for less.
Yeah. OK. So, any other thoughts
about the adjectives
that you're seeing?
OK.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah.
>> There's a lot more
specificity in the '70s.
Like environmental, military and
private, a lot of the adjectives
in the 30s are more-- I guess
there's economic there too
but small, large,
serious, bold, you know,
they're just generic adjectives.
>> Eleanor Dickson: In the '30s?
>> In the '30s.
>> Eleanor Dickson:
Yeah, that's interesting.
So we can think about the kind
of analysis that you just did
and then what we're going
to do while we make
this quick visualization
as exploratory data analysis.
So this sort of hits
back on that theme
of the research process
as iterative
or not progressing
in a linear fashion.
So oftentimes, the researcher
especially, you know,
you have these JSON files.
They're zipped up.
It sort of it feels
a little black boxy,
but what the researcher is
going to do is do something
like create that data
frame and get a feel
for what are these
underscores, right?
This doesn't make sense.
And then they need to think OK,
is there something
weird about my data?
Is there something weird about
the process that I'm using?
And that's sort of this
going through the process
like starting a little bit,
looking at what you have
because it would be
basically impossible to open
up these 19 JSON files and read
through them with the human eye
and notice those trends.
So that's what exploratory
data analysis allows us to do.
Get familiar with data,
recognize patterns
and potential problems.
It's really hard to see
those trends if you're say
like opening a massive CSV file
to get a feel for what's there.
So this exploratory approach
helps us understand the contours
of the data.
So some basic exploratory
data analysis strategies are
to plot raw data,
plot simple statistics
and then maybe do
some comparison
between different
plots to get an idea
of what's the same
and what's different.
OK. So we have this sort of
like, oh, we're going to talk
about visualization for a couple
of minutes and then we're going
to talk about it again more
later as much later as we have.
OK. So in-- we just want to
mention while we're still though
on the track of thinking
about Python,
that in Python there
are libraries
for doing data visualization.
So matplotlib, there's pyplot.
That's a function that
allows for visualization.
And then there's also a
library that's called ggplot.
And then in R, there's a
library called ggplot2.
And then you might hear
people talk about D3.js.
That's a JavaScript library
for doing visualizations.
So these are the kinds
of visualization tools,
libraries that the more advanced
researcher might use in order
to create those kinds of bar
graphs and things like that
that we're going to
play within a second.
OK. I hear typing, so pausing.
So we are going to look at
the word count by page in one
of the volumes from the
1970s presidential speeches.
So it's presidential
papers of the presidents
of the United States, one
of the Gerald Ford volumes.
I can't remember if
he has more than one,
but it is a Gerald Ford volume.
All right.
So we're going to run a script
called word count dot py
and it's going to create a
nice visualization for you
and then we're going to think
about what that looks like.
All right.
So you see here that the script
I'm just going to show it to you
on the slide, we're
importing the modules here,
which includes matplotlib's
pyplot as PLT.
The PLT is just laziness so that
when you want to use it again,
you just have to write
PLT and not matplotlib.
And then we are going to create
a file that's called words.png.
So when you run the
script, it's going to look
like nothing happened
but then go back and look
at your file viewer list
and you'll see a new
one called words.png.
So why don't you go ahead
and run this command.
This is one that doesn't
require any arguments.
We'll notice that there's
not a dot, sys.argv.
That's not a requirement
for a Python script.
This one, it's hard
coded into the script,
the file that we're going
to open up and plot.
>> Can you go back to the
filename we're supposed to--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
So the filename that we're
running is word count--
word underscore count dot py.
And then you'll see that if it
goes OK, I don't get an error.
And then I can go back and
look at my list of files.
And I'll see that I now have a
file that's called words.png.
If I clicked to download it,
it just opens it in the window.
So right away, I noticed
some interesting things here.
Do you have your file up?
What are you seeing?
Yeah. So we see at the-- up
to probably about page 100,
there are fewer words.
So maybe that's in table
of contents or in index
or something like that.
But then what do
we see from there?
It's pretty steady, right?
And then there's these
two huge spikes and I want
to know what those mean, right?
So if I were doing this as part
of exploratory work, I would go,
huh, did I write the code wrong
or is there really one page here
that has over a thousand
words on it?
Or maybe it got tokenized
in an interesting way?
Maybe it's a table with, I don't
know, a thousand numbers on it
and those got tokenized
separately.
I don't know.
So this is the sort of
thing that a researcher--
you would create the sort of
visualization and then you'd go,
OK, I need to dig back into
the data and get a feel
for what that means for me.
>> And we could break over that
JSON file and go to that page.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah, yeah.
So you could open
up to that JSON file
and go down to that page.
[ Inaudible ]
Yup, yup, yup.
And there are some
researchers who do things
like when the work is not in
the public domain will go check
in an actual lib like
physical lib-- actual library.
Yeah?
>> So what are we
actually seeing here?
>> Eleanor Dickson:
So we're seeing words
by page in one volume.
So on the bottom, the
x-axis, we're seeing page
and then along the y-axis,
we're seeing words per page.
>> And is it in order?
>> Eleanor Dickson:
Page number order.
>> Right. So it's
page 800 something?
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes, yes.
>> OK. So then you can go
to the physical volume--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes.
>> -- and start--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yup, yup.
And say, huh, did I do it wrong?
Is the tokenization wrong?
What is happening here?
Maybe it's a really interesting
thing I want to look at.
Or maybe it's not interesting at
all but at least you've looked.
Yeah, go ahead.
>> So if you wanted to
change the x and y axis
for whatever reason or to
further granulize the chart,
you want to go into
the word count dot py--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes, yeah.
>> -- make those
changes yourself.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes, yeah.
You would have to pull
out something different
for what you wanted to look at,
specify what you wanted to look
at and then pyplot, the
tool we're using here
to do the visualization, you
can set different parameters
for how the x and y
axis are displayed,
like there are some
customization that you can do.
>> So you would do that in the--
>> Eleanor Dickson: In
the script still, yeah.
>> In the scripts
or in the matplot?
>> Eleanor Dickson:
In the script, yes.
Yup. And you would just call
out to matplotlib, that library,
say, you know, I'm using you
but I want you when you run
to make this picture to be green
or show this on the x-axis.
Yeah.
>> OK.
>> Eleanor Dickson:
Any other questions?
Yeah?
>> Just to curve what you said,
even though it's extracting
on the copy written material
and it's running the whole,
so it's running it, it will say
this is in volume 15 page 5.
So giving that specificity,
but then you have to have
that file separately because
it's a partial view over.
>> Eleanor Dickson:
Well, I guess it depends
on what you think
of as partial view.
So if it's enough
to do the checking
to have the word counts,
then you have them there
in the extracted features file.
>> If you wanted to do
further analysis and you wanted
to do a closed reading--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
You would have to go back
to the original file.
Yeah, yeah.
Yes, yeah.
Yeah. Yup?
>> The actual JSON files,
you can't actually
view that and then--
>> Eleanor Dickson:
Yeah, you can.
Let's look at one
really quickly.
So if you want to open it,
remember we used unzip before.
We use-- it's called bunzip2.
All right.
And then you're going to
put in the name of the file.
Actually, let me just
see what's there.
I'm going to copy and paste.
So I'm going to unzip
one of these.
OK.
OK. Any other questions
while I'm doing this?
And then there's the JSON.
It's not pretty printed
but there's all
of the information there.
The nice thing about that
feature reader library is
that you don't have to unzip the
file which is-- and for-- sorry.
For getting your
feet wet with it,
it feels like there's
a barrier there, right,
like there's some disconnect
between you and the file.
But if you're working with
loads of data, then having it
in a compressed format is
better because you're taking
up less space on your machine.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes, yeah.
That it doesn't know
how to read the JSON.
Yeah. OK. So we are doing great
and we are going
to-- we did this.
I'm actually doing
really well on time.
I'll say briefly that when they
did this example that you looked
at earlier, that
machine learning project
that we have talked
about a couple times now,
they use extracted
features data for that work.
So that was all using
extracted features.
OK. All right.
Let's talk about Sam again.
OK. So now we're going to--
almost the end of
our time with Sam.
So Sam now that he
has his data prepared.
It's reduced down to just
the text he wants to look at,
then Sam did topic
modeling only on those pages
where his search term appeared.
And he ends up with the
topics that show the changes
and the use of the
word creativity
over the 20th century.
So now he's graphing the
use of the topics over time.
So it's small but at the top
we see the words that are
in that topic and then
you see the probability
that it would occur
over time going down.
So it's just a different
way of viewing the topics.
But we see that over time
creativity becomes used less
in topics that include words
like, God, Christ, Jesus,
creation, word, species,
animals, natural, plants, soil,
invention, power
creative, own, ideas.
And we see it going up in
topics that include words
like advertising,
media, marketing, poetry,
language, poets, poems.
So based on these two ways
of looking at that data
and those changes, Sam was
able to make the argument
in this chapter of
his dissertation
that he used this work
in to say that the usage
of the word creativity
changed over the 20th century
to move away from thinking about
creation as a generative thing
like this was created into
talking about it in terms
of artistic or a productive
creativity in that sort of space
where we think about in terms
of art and things like that.
Yeah?
>> Well, [inaudible] to go read
the dissertation [inaudible]
but I want to make sure
I understand what--
I think he said-- so
using just the pages
that had variations
on the word created.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yes.
>> So are those each
a separate chunk?
>> Eleanor Dickson: You
know, I don't know how he fed
that into the topic
model [inaudible].
That's a good question.
>> But like-- so somehow
he told them he's in JSON
that identified things by page?
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah, yeah.
So he was using the
extracted features files.
So he just used those
words-- the word counts.
>> So, where they appear on the
page and he pulled that out?
>> Eleanor Dickson: He pulled--
Yeah, all the other words.
Yeah.
>> OK. So somehow
[inaudible] chunk them off.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
It might be at the
page level still.
Yeah.
>> But then having to
get a graph over time.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
So I think that they
took those probabilities
so they would have said--
try to think about how
they would have done this.
They said-- I saw this topic
advertising, media, marketing,
sales, television occur
not very many times
when I did the topic
modeling by year.
I think they did it for every
year, modeled every year,
but I did see it a lot in 2000
and then they've
made that chart.
Does that make sense?
>> No. Because I thought
the topics were derived
from the text so you couldn't
go and look for the same topic
and it-- like say
you had the 18--
the 1970 data and
the 1930 data--
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
>> -- you wouldn't expect
to find the exact same topic
in each one because the topics
are derived from the data.
You don't impose the topic and
look for it in both places.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah.
So I think that-- go ahead.
>> My understanding with that--
so those are like
example words, right?
>> Eleanor Dickson: Uh-huh,
that would occur in that topic.
Yeah.
>> So that you wouldn't
search for like advertising
in the same-- on the same
page as that would be
like for all the
things and then--
and then like the
one in the 1950s.
>> So, you think those were
occurrences of those words?
>> Yeah, exactly
like [inaudible].
>> Oh, see, I--
>> Eleanor Dickson: I don't--
>> [Inaudible] this
because I'm not sure I--
>> Eleanor Dickson: I
don't know that that's true
but how they got from
the topics or the topics
over time, I'm not quite sure--
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. I don't know if they broke
the text out into like pieces
but it has something to
do with the likelihood
that that topic was going
to occur in that year.
Yeah. Go ahead.
>> So I mean do you think that
they-- one way would then--
is to do what had overall kind
of these are the words that come
up generally and then--
but in year by year
so you do the overall
on the entire purpose
or [inaudible]
that list then back in--
>> Eleanor Dickson:
I don't think so.
I think it's more like
he either took snippets
that would have been
year by year
or he did one big topic
model and then the output
of however he did it said
that it was occurring--
the topic had a high
prevalence in these volumes
that were published
in these years,
maybe that's how
they did the-- yeah.
>> [Inaudible] exploratory and
then refining your [inaudible].
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah, yeah.
OK. Any other questions?
That's a good question.
Yeah?
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, that's a good point.
>> It's just interesting
how he chose to depict it
because it makes it look like
they're all about the same kind
of terms [inaudible]
normalized y-axis.
>> Eleanor Dickson: Yeah,
that's a great point.
So for the purposes of wherever
I grabbed these visualizations
from whatever report
he had done, yeah,
they tried to make the steepness
of the line look
the same, right?
But you're pointing
out that the scale
on the y-axis are different
for the different charts.
So we get the impact here
of the trend going down
but it might look more drastic
than it would otherwise
feel potentially.
Yeah. Any other thoughts here?
OK. So it was always the
awkward spot we end up in.
Do you want us to have
a nice discussion,
do the wrap up to our
survey or do you want
to do 10-minute play time
with a visualization tool?
Let's use the tool.
You all look really
[laughter] full of energy.
All right.
So if you wanted to go
and go through the rest
of this module 5 about data
visualization, then you're--
I would recommend watching
the recording that we did
and I'll show you where
that is at the very end.
But I'm going to skip down
to where there's a link here
and we're going to
play with Bookworm.
All right.
So before we open it
up, we talked earlier
about N-gram inclusion.
So N-gram-- just as a reminder,
an N-gram is a contiguous
chain of n item.
So where n is the number
from a sequence of text.
So you could have a unit gram,
that's one word, a bigram,
that's two, trigram,
that's three.
And oftentimes when you're
creating bigrams like--
or creating N-grams like
these bigrams in the box here,
we're seeing that it's sort of
a sliding scale over the text.
So one bigram is four score
and the next must score
n and then n7, 7 years.
So, sort of moving along.
And so that's the text that
we're going to be playing with,
the visualization tool,
the text that it's running
on is the N-grams or unigrams.
So I always think like,
oh, wouldn't it be fun
if I just searched city names?
I'm from California
and then you say like,
I can't do Los Angeles.
So you can't put in a
bigram in the search bar.
We're going to do unigrams only.
All right.
So we're playing with
a tool called Bookworm.
And Bookworm is a-- how many
of you have played
with Google N-grams?
Yeah. So Bookworm is like ht or
sys version of Google N-grams.
So, some of the same
people who worked
on the original Google
N-gram viewer worked
on this project also.
But the benefit we see here,
we lose out on phrase searching
but we get the benefit
of a library metadata.
So if you have the analytics
site open and you click
on explore up at the very top,
you don't have to be logged in.
And then the first link
under explore is
HathiTrust plus Bookworm.
Click try it now.
And then you'll see that it's
pretty populated with polka.
Just an interesting choice.
And then you can
search for your n terms.
So if you add words
to search here and--
yeah, you end up with
two different bars.
So every word is its
own bar on the graph
so you're not graphing
them on one line.
There will be two
separate lines.
And then if you click on this
thing that looks like a funnel,
you can facet your text.
So limit it based on the
bibliographic metadata.
So you can narrow it
down based on language,
publication country, publication
state, the classification terms.
>> Can you get down to the
specific journal title?
>> Eleanor Dickson: So you--
The thing that you can
do is click on the line.
Sometimes it takes a
second especially in Chrome.
There we go.
And it will pull up every
place where the word occurred.
>> Can you search
only on the specific--
>> Eleanor Dickson: No, yeah.
That would be cool, huh.
And then I recommend control
clicking or right clicking
to open because it
opens in the same tab
and if you go back your
visualization is lost.
And then the other thing
that you can do here is play
around with either the
dates, the metrics.
So I was doing words per million
to try to normalize for the fact
that there was more
text produced over time
so you don't want
to do raw counts
because then you'd always think
that things are more prevalent
later in time than earlier.
So there's some balancing
the choice you have
by doing words per million.
And then you can also
do case sensitive
versus insensitive depending on
the word that you're searching.
So I'll give you a few minutes
to play here, just like two
or three minutes, see if you
find anything interesting.
I think that puts pressure on
people, so also not interesting,
but it's always fun to
see what people search.
I went down the path one time
to learn about the history
of vaccines because
I thought, oh,
wouldn't vaccine be interesting?
And then you get these blips
that are OCR errors that have
to do with the Latin for
cow and then I learned
about how the first
vaccines were for cowpox.
So it was like oh look, the
tool taught me something
that I wasn't expecting to know.
So it can be useful.
All right.
Anything else someone
wants to share?
We have about 10 minutes
so we can probably
move into our wrap up.
If you are interested in--
let me get this webpage up,
if you're interested in learning
more about visualization
at least the way that
we are talking about it
in this project, well,
you go look through the
curriculum materials or--
We did a series of webinars
leading up to this week.
We haven't put the last one on
the web yet but we will soon.
So they started in
May and they went
through August 1 in a month.
And the first one was
me doing the state
of visualization module
because I don't know
that we have ever gotten
to it in a workshop,
so you are not alone in the
fact that you did not get
through the whole thing.
So yeah, we put it up there
so that people could enjoy
if they wanted to or watch it.
I don't know if they enjoyed it.
And then we have data management
and then we have this
mining newspaper data.
Harriett mentioned that earlier.
That's all about using R to mine
the Library of Congress, the--
chronicling America
newspapers dataset.
And then the last one
that happened this week was a
librarian from the University
of Iowa talking about a research
collaboration she's been
involved in where it was-- she
was part of a research team
at Iowa that partnered with
HTRC on a research project.
And so what it was like for
her to provide that sort
of library oriented
text analysis support
within that project team.
So again, all these materials
are there for you to use,
reuse if you would like.
All right.
With our last few minutes, I'll
just put the slide up again
that shows the names of
all the folks who've worked
on this project.
There have been many.
And let you know that
if you have questions
after the workshop, you are
more than welcome to contact us
at the email address
that's on the screen.
So it's HTRC underscore
workshop@library.illinois.edu.
If you have specific
questions about the contents,
reusing the content
on what we covered
and then you can also refer
back to the project website.
We've been piloting a software
platform called comments
in a box.
Are any of you familiar with
comments in a box, for all folks
who have attended the workshops
since we started doing them,
so you will likely see an
invitation to the comments
in a box instance
for this project.
And there's some conversation
that happens on that forum
about ways people have
reused the curriculum,
examples they've seen of
text analysis projects,
help getting started,
that sort of thing.
So if you see the invitation,
you're more than obviously
welcome to joint that group
and join in the conversation.
But other than that,
we are done.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.